Hey Oak's the only group here.
>> What? Why did you say that? That is an explicit move
to like coordinate and to cut certain opinions out of the rightwing
entirely. >> Crumble Cookie sponsored me. I like their
cookies already. I already ate them before that. You guys knew
that. So, who cares if I'm sponsored and don't disclose it? >> Guys,
you're not watching enough. You're not subbing enough. I can't
afford to pay my employees anymore. >> Sorry. You're saying
a comedian? Okay. I >> Yes. a Democratic comedian and content
creator on Instagram is how Taylor Loren describes her. You go
on her Instagram.
>> I do not want to find out in 3 years that you are
a racist. >> I'm not a racist. >> That's just what's
important to me right >> Okay. Yeah, I'm not racist.
>> Are you a
>> A curious person would wonder why I could answer that
one so quickly and not the racist one so quickly, but it's
>> Olivia Juliana. Is this the >> just the big lady?
I heard I heard Straighter Aid was calling this woman a fat piece
of today. Is that true that Straighter Raid was calling this
woman like a a ham planet?
Straight was totally mocking this woman's weight. That's up.
I can't believe Straight Raid did this. I believe Straight Raid
said that this woman has Arby's in her pants. What the [__]
does that even mean? What is What the [__] does that
mean? So, I think Chorus wants to set itself up as a middleman
between politicians and
And these are the tools they're using to do it. If anybody's
forward thinking, hey, I want to be able to to basically, you
know, for my for my own purposes book Democrat politicians with
influencers, right? I want to be the person, the go-to for that,
right? I I want to set myself up as the go-to for that. Well,
if I get influencers to let me know when they set something up
with an with a politician, with some expert that I might be unaware
of, I want to know that name cuz I want to get the heads up that
I'm going to go and start adding them to my network. Is that
nefarious? Not necessarily.
But I do understand why people might want to keep their business
contacts private. Pisco and straight raid had an argument for
like an hour over whether funneling is fair.
I listen, I think there's reasons to be concerned about it. I
don't Is funneling fair? bundling might be like 30% aggressive
in terms of like a Alexa. Can I call in? Yeah, sure. Hold on.
Oh
>> yo. Okay. So, the thing that we got stuck on is do you
have the the wild wired article pulled up? Yeah, you do, >> I
do. Yep. >> Okay. Go to where she control FF funnel. >> One
second. I just need to set I'm just setting something up. Give
me one second here. Uh oh, that's why. Sorry, I'm just setting
up the uh thing on screen here. >> No, you're good. >> Okay,
I'm actually gonna put this here and move this out of the way.
Okay. All right. So, go to
uh politician
if I want to work. This is about where it is. Following the initial
outreach, many creators expressed concern about some stipulations.
According to copies of the contract view by Wired, creators in
the program must funnel all bookings with lawmakers and political
leaders through Chorus. Creators also have to loop course in
on any independently organized engagements with government officials
or political leaders. Okay. Yes. So I said sorry I did say this
all here this all.
>> I think this is where they up right. Funnel all but
funnel should funnel mustfunnel will use courses like details
to book lawmaker. >> Well that actually wasn't where we
got tripped up on the language cuz if you go to the to the contract
um to where the Tik Tocker shows like the the contract language
specifically.
>> Okay. Notice that it says
um like one and keep in mind this this is not the entire contract.
There are over 90 creators part of this this pilot pilot program
apparently. So we're presupposing that they all had the same
uh contract when it may have been the case that some creators
were able to get you know adjustments. I know that even a larger
creator like take it or leave it different cohorts right there.
There's the amplifier cohort which is different which is mentioned
in here. So that would imply I assume two different contracts
or different >> and when David Pacman's response I don't
know if you've seen that he said that he has like a mentorship
role so he probably has different stipulations than somebody
who's in a creator like an upand cominging one and like a middle
tier one like there's you know within 90 I get 90 different participants
I don't I I would be shocked that not a single one has a contract
that is maybe different from some of the others right uh but
the language there says like for uh clause to disclose to Chorus
newsroom personnel any engagements with government officials
or others
like who is or others referring to on topics related to Chorus'
policy agenda that contractor arranges through other means and
then it gets to clause three but that or others thing would that
mean that like okay so they've made a delineation between government
officials and then like who like does that involve creators streamers
>> right if you look above it says uh chorus will provide
contractors with access to the Chorus newsroom which coordinates
booking and engagement opportunities for creators with government
officials, policy and nonprofit experts and others whose expertise
and experiences are relevant to Chorus's progressive policy agenda.
I'm guessing others encompasses all of everything there except
for government
>> But he's saying he like Pisco was saying where does
the line start and end with whose expertise and experiences are
relevant to Chorus's progressive policy agenda because that's
very subjective and it's open-ended. So that could mean like
like he was like if I'm talking to somebody who is not an expert
he's who like doesn't run a think tank or but is just like a
large kind of like political hobbyist that has a big following
or something like that. Do I need to disclose to them? And he
said that that seemed absurd. And so by leaving out that the
or others it meant that there was actually room for them to not
have to disclose
uh like to chorus every single thing that they're doing. And
so it's dishonest to say that they necessarily had to loop in
everybody, which is another way that she characterizes that the
uh this area of the contract if we're assuming that this is the
area of the contract that's relevant to that portion of the article.
>> I I mean I think that's pretty fair to assume. Man,
I I think it's pretty reasonable to read it is like they do need
to like by looping in or or funneling, I assume it means you
need to like Chorus should be aware of all the people you're
interviewing who are >> Well, by funneling, I said that
as well. I agreed. I was like, "That seems like funneling to
me." But then he said, "If if I say to you, I want you to funnel
uh like your engagement with this creator, go through me, like
funnel it through me." He was like, "They that probably means
you have to like CC and be emailing them on every single like
be part of every single part of the communication from that point
going forward." And I can see how I think that that's what funnel
means. Why not? Why do why don't you think so? Because I was
convinced by the end of our conversation that I do think that
funnel could mean that. and loop in is just that's a notification
that's just a disclosure and then there's no other communication
that they're
>> I think oh sorry in this case because so be actually
I'm going to change my mind here because I think um I think funnel
refers to one and loopin refers to two right and to me like one
utilize the chorus newsroom to book engagements I think this
is not specific enough to really know
what exactly that means like it to me I think you have to assume
unless otherwise stated somewhere that it means if you if you
want to you'll use it. I maybe you could say agrees to utilize
the course. Does that mean like to book an engagement that you
could book elsewhere or otherwise? >> Well, that was the
thing that we got into at the end. What is the difference between
um like a booking and an engagement opportunity? Is like is that
an interview? Is that a a conversation? Is that distinct from
a a collaboration? Like like and they like it even says like
in the third clause collaboration. And so again, we've made a
distinction in this contract between a booking, between an engagement
opportunity, and between a collaboration. And we don't really
know what chorus newsroom even even refers to. Does a newsroom
refer to a physical location? Does it refer to a remote location?
Does it refer to a collection of employees? Somebody in his chat
said it refers to a spe a special type of proprietary software
that uh Chorus uses. So, all of this is ambiguous and that's
why I'm saying that like we need to like we need to wait for
there to be someone to leak the whole
>> I'm positive this is software.
>> Really? Is it proprietary? Let me >> uh It's probably
not proprietary. It's probably um it's probably using some existing
backend that that handles this. This is like just um this is
like sales stuff like pretty simple sales stuff. like you have
leads, you have like contacts and stuff and you can basically
reach out to them and and use some software here to to coordinate.
I'm guessing like I'm guessing you could actually modify Salesforce
like super slightly and make this work. Ri's like on my page.
I I think you could just basically modify Salesforce like slightly.
Yeah. HubSpot, Salesforce, anything like that for for managing
leads.
Um that's how it looks to me. That's why the funnel thing made
me think of like leads and it could be number two. I want to
see what three is here as well. Does she ever like get her head
out of the [__] >> I don't think it's like
it's a 10minute video and I don't think she ever moves her fat
away from the contract which is all anyone wants to see. These
people will post these 10 minute videos of them yapping yapping
yapping. Uh David Pacman did it, Brian Tyler Cohen did it. It's
like can you all just show the contract and we can evaluate it
for ourselves? That is really the only way to put this to rest.
If they lied, show the contract. Prove it to people. It's that
simple to And I think it would if it was, here's the thing, if
it was obvious that Chorus was lying and like this was clearly
malicious, clearly like explicitly worded to like try to be as
controlling as possible, I think Taylor would post the contracts.
And I think from the other end, if it was clearly like exculpatory,
I think Chorus would put would uh post the contracts. I think
the fact that it's like in between, Chorus knows they probably
got caught doing some they shouldn't have and looks like slightly
shady. And to me, I think although they might be on the wired
side that they have like agreements, there might be actual journalistic
agreements like I'm not going to share this cuz it could out
you like maybe you got a contract that somehow worded that cuts
it down. >> It says directly on the chorus website that
there is there is like some it's kind of opaque. Hold on, let
me see. I'll link it to you
where they talk about uh cuz there is a page that talks about
being in this specific program,
this incubator.
I would just say that the thing that I'm like getting more annoyed
about or I am more annoyed about is one the transparent and obvious
lie that they all brought up about uh Taylor Loren, >> right?
Like they actually are just lying about her. The uh the funding
from Omidian
doesn't get any money.
>> Yeah, she doesn't get any money from them. Even if she
did, who cares? Contend with the arguments that are outlined
in the article. I don't see why it's so overpersonalized.
Well, I I think it's crazy to run with that lie because the criticisms
and imply hypocrisy because the criticisms she's making is about
dark money. If she's getting money through the Omidian Foundation
that's run for uh sorry, Midiar, Amidar, Amidar Foundation that's
run for Pier Midiar, that's Pier Odiar putting money into that
foundation. That's transparent, right? Whether or not Pier Midar
is one of the non-transparent
dark money funders of 1630 is irrelevant, right?
like like that the the whole 1630 pipeline is irrelevant to what
the Omidar network is actually doing. And Taylor Loren uh she
has disclosed on that site as a as a recipient. People literally
could look it up immediately to see how much she was getting
paid. And uh the the name of the guy is like that's his foundation.
That's his thing. So like it's transparent on both ends.
>> But on but on the 1630 side fund side it is opaque coming
in. You don't know how much Omidiar is putting into it and they're
not disclosing or apparently the the accusation is their contracts
are saying we're not you can't disclose this and again it all
comes down to the contract there but that would be dark at both
ends. So the idea that there's some hypocrisy here is so laughably
stupid.
I feel like people should be embarrassed for trying to run with
this. Like this
over here puts up a graphic
literally showing this exactly that Pier Midar gives money to
Omidar Network and 1630 fund. Okay, this is not transparent.
Nobody could look this up. The only reason you know about it
is because Brian Tyler Cohen asked. That's the only reason anyone
knows about it. >> Did you notice that one of the like
screenshots posted it had like source equals chat GPT? Oh, that
like saying it was Yeah, like they described it from like Cha
GPT. Yeah. Yeah. Well, it doesn't mean she's lying. It just means
that like this was not
>> I just thought it was funny. I just thought it was funny.
>> Apparently, Taylor Loren just responded to one of the
to somebody from Pod Save America retweeting something about
this, like retweeting one of the Tik Tok
Let's check it out. >> But look at the chorus website cuz
it says, "Will I be publicly listed as a chorus creator? Your
privacy and safety is a top priority for us and therefore we
don't list individual participants in the program. We also ask
chorus members to refrain from discussing the program details
for these reasons. >> Oh wait, >> go to FAQ at the
bottom. The last >> Will I be posting this later? >> We
ask them to refrain. It's like well do you contractually obligate
them to or do you just is that a suggestion? >> I mean
it seems like it's more than a
like it seems like it wouldn't be just a guideline because again
if if you if the whole point is like we're concerned about creator
privacy and all of that then I think the only way for you to
really help those creator feel at ease then it kind of you would
be able to promise to them well it's contractually mandated that
they can't discuss that you're in it and you can't discuss that
they're in it and there's also a non-disparagement clause so
you guys can't talk about each other without being in breach
of contract. The non-disparagement clause seems like one of the
biggest things where they if there is a non-disparagement clause,
I've not seen that yet, but if there is of other creators that
you get to know all the other creators and basically once that
grows big enough, you're basically not talking like half of the
internet if it could if it could scale enough, right? You're
like potentially not half of political influencers. Let's say
most people join this, right?
>> So like that is in fact controlling people's content.
>> The thing to also keep in mind is that like it's a stipen.
So, the money is not exactly fungeable. They're not just given
an $8,000 check a month. They have to I'm pretty sure they have
to tell Chorus how they're spending every single penny of that
$8,000 or whatever their budget is that they're allocated for
that month. And so that is effectively like kind of gatekeeping
because it does say in the article like you can't use those funds
to um to fund some sort of like again if you contact Zoran Mani
or whatever and you want to use funds from your stipend towards
that. You can't just use it without like looping in chorus and
you can say and people can say that's legit but like that is
I think what's happening there. Sorry, I just responded something
in chat and then um >> sorry, I want to pull up this Taylor
Loren tweet as well.
>> Like any other small business who receives seed money,
>> one tokver, you think this is the exact same as a small
business that receives seed money. Do you understand that in
those cases the the the way you receive seed money? Do you know
how you do that? You offer a piece of your thing back to them,
right? That is the that is the positive thing. You might even
have some contract stipulations that say you can't do things.
This is about journalism. is about people talking about politics,
right? You're paying them for political speech. If you have restrictions
on that speech, that is not the same as a seed funding as seed
funding, right? Seed funding wouldn't make any sense if they
told you, "Oh, also you can't use the uh you can't use like a
process. Here's some mechanical process or some chemical process
for doing stuff, right? That would be that would be very different
than just normal seed funding. That would be something totally
different. Now, there's not really ethical obligations there,
but like it's not the same thing. Uh grant versus stipen versus
bery. I don't want to h I Dickers I don't know sorry Dicker's
asking cyp is for particular purchases I've heard this that like
they basically have control over if you're using the money for
stuff that's related to anything involved with them you have
to loop them in or credit them right that's >> why they
call it a scholarship program but he does kind of but it's weird
because I swear Brian also said I swear I remember he says we
want to give creators the ability to like do this full-time and
not have to worry about anything else so maybe within the contract
it says that some of the stipen be spent on uh living expenses.
But I guess any of that siphoned is related to any content generation
and it happens to involve an expert, a government official, etc.
Then they have to be looped in. There's no doing it on your own.
There's only like doing it with Chorus and maybe Chorus has the
ability to reject if you if like no, we don't we don't want you
talking to Zorn because like again, this is another assumption
on my part, but I don't think it's too crazy. Like if Assan had
this sort of org, I wouldn't be surprised if an ideological prerequisite
effectively is that you can't be a Zionist. And similarly, when
I look at Brian Tyler Cohen as a co-founder and he says in his
response, I and many other creators uh have condemned what >> I
I >> Be careful about what? >> Nothing. Never mind.
We We love Israel here. Okay, I'm going to play the music. We're
going to play the Israeli theme song here real quick. Okay. >> What
is going on? >> Whoops. That's not it. That's not it. We're
going to play the Israeli theme song here. Okay. So that we Everybody
knows we love the people, okay? Before anything anything gets
said. All right,
we love them. We love them. There's no anti-semitism here. We're
just being safe, okay? We're just being safe. Thank you for flagging
up in the chat, guys. Sorry. Go ahead. Brian Tyler Cohen pretended
that he's ever called out the genocide in Gaza. >> He said
there we have videos, me, myself, and other creators where we
have condemned the atrocities in Gaza. I went on his channel
and I could not find any mention of to the I went on his Twitter
in 20 in in 2023. There was nothing. In 2024, there was one mention
of the Gaza of Gaza and it was to say that's not a reason to
not vote for Joe Biden or Kla Harris. You should still vote against
Donald Trump. You still vote for these people cuz you're not
going to punish them. And then everything else un like was saying
that Elon Musk has perpetuated lies about condoms in Gaza and
like just it was unrelation
of atrocities. Okay, I go on his YouTube channel. I don't find
anything like that. Somebody linked me an interview where he
said Gaza is like not in his lane, but that you can have your
disagreements with the Democratic party over that, but he doesn't
know enough to speak on that. I guess there's something in history
book that's going to justify dropping bombs on kids or something
that he feels he needs to know first before he condemns that.
And then when I go to >> moral army on planet Earth, most
moral army on planet Earth. Okay. most moral
um
I so I just could I couldn't find it and like I couldn't even
find him talking about Zoran Mani. This guy pretends that he's
a progressive influencer in 2020. There's almost no mention of
Bernie Sanders on his on his platform or on his channel when
Bernie Sanders was obviously the most progressive candidate in
the Democratic field at that point. So how he didn't support
Bernie but called himself a progressive is weird to me. And now
there's no mention of Zoran Mani. There was no mention of Cuomo
to the I I searched Brian Tyler Cohen Zoran and there's one clip
from Brian Tyler Cohen and it's not him giving any commentary
on Zor. It's not him saying he supports him or endorsing him
or praising his campaign, his win, nothing. It's only a clip
of Zorani like dunking on Trump. This dude just seems like a
run-of-the-mill like a standard like moderate like lib to me.
He doesn't seem like a progressive. >> I mean, he's obviously
a lib.
He's obviously just like a a total lib like Yeah, he's >> incredible.
Yes, it is. Thank you. I do think that you should if you're a
progressive, you would be excited about Zoran Mdani, an open
Democratic socialist uh succeeding in New York City and like
potentially becoming mayor. Yeah, he's the only person in the
Democratic party that's like young and has aura right now. That
when the Dem's approval rating is in the at like 30
>> Um I think I still think like BTC BTC is uh probably
a good example of what like the majority of demoters think to
be honest with you. I understand that like Zoran's exciting right
now. I think I just think BTC happens to be like a pretty good
example because I think the goal of this channel is to figure
out what's the most popular opinion and then to have that opinion
basically. Like I think >> I only brought all this up because
like I was saying like again if had this or you probably wouldn't
include Zionists and I wouldn't be surprised since Brian Tyler
Cohen is a co-founder that they're not really that interested
in people that are outspoken about the Gaza genocide or are really
like massive critics of Israel because like you're saying they
want to cast a broad net appeal to as many people as possible
and that includes not being super pro- Israel but it also includes
not being very very critical of them just avoiding it entirely.
I mean, >> um, I I think that's probably true. I would
be shocked if they grab a couple creators just to avoid that
who like are quite critical of Israel but are mostly like libs
outside of that. >> I I would be shocked if they didn't
do that cuz I think that that was something that I noticed right
away was people were basically like, "Oh, this is like uh just
clearly Israeli funded or something and that's something he soyed
about." So, I've just I've been very like clear. I've seen no
evidence that there's any Zionist money going into this that
there's like Yeah. I just been very clear because like I don't
want to get lumped in with those people making that. I don't
think you're doing it either by the way, but I just don't want
to be lumped in with people who are who are going to like try
to make this about like I don't want to have an argument. I'm
excited about this because it's a political argument and it doesn't
have to do with anti-semitism. So, for the love of God, everybody
wants to turn this into something about anti-semitism. Please
walk the on. Please walk away. Get the [__] away
from me. Okay? It's it's so exciting that we could have an issue
that's not having to do with anti-semitism or Israel Palestine.
Don't corrupt this one, too, guys. Okay? Please, please. >> I
saw what somebody put in my chat, uh, like
David A. Pac-Man, and I was like, I realize that rolls off the
tongue, but like, stop putting that because there's no evidence
or reason to think that David Pacman is only a Zionist, because
he is paid by a special interest group, specifically Apac, because
he he just wouldn't be. For one, I think it's is it so hard to
believe that some people are just ideologically committed Zionists?
They didn't need money to believe that. They already just thought
that he's one of those people. He just is. >> He's like
uh Ted Cruz. Ted Cruz just woke up one day and said he was going
to be the strongest defender of Israel, guys. Israel. Woke up
one day.
Yeah. Yeah. That's that was maybe the most insane thing I've
heard said in in an interview before. I just I decided I was
going to be Israel's strongest defender and that's why I ran
for Congress. It's
what? Why did you say that? Uh okay. I want to get to this tweet
really quickly. I don't know if you saw this. Well, maybe not
cuz it just happened an hour and a half ago. John Favro retweets
the the thing from Ali and says, "The atwired piece is wildly
dishonest and I'm truly surprised they published it."
Uh, Hutch responds, "Oh boy, they're going to come for you for
saying this. Steal yourself for the psychos." And Emma Vigland
responds, "What specifically is dishonest? Hasn't Wired earned
its reputation as a thorough and diligent publication with it
excellent reporting on Trump, Doge, Epstein, etc. I believe this
is where Taylor comes in is somewhere after this. Yes, John.
What is dishonest? There's a slew of misleading information in
the video you shared, but ironically, the contract section she
shows actually corroborates a bunch of the reporting that's in
the piece. Gorus reached out post publication, and Wired has
not issued a single correction or retraction on the story. Our
reporting was based on copies of contracts, internal emails,
text messages discussing the deal, a record a recorded Zoom onboarding
session, and testimony from 16:30 creators. >> Yeah, they're
updates. That's different from a retraction
because the people that had they had reached out to again there's
all over this article. It's like we could not reach this person
for comment. They declined to to make a comment. Then the article
drops and all of a sudden they all have a lot to say and then
some people decided that like yeah we wanted to comment. So the
the update from the wired article says what does it say? I have
it open right here. Update on the 28th of August 7 p.m. EDT.
Following the publication of this article, Graham Wilson of the
Elias Law Firm, whose participation in a Zoom call was reported
upon and who did not respond to Wired's pre-publication email
requesting comment, reached out to Wired on several points. These
include whether members of the cohort can publicly talk about
working with Chorus and Chorus' connection to good influence,
both of which Wy has clarified. We also have included comment
from Wilson regarding Chorus placing quote unquote restrictions
on content and whether V. Spear was included in any chorus materials.
So, I have not gone through the updated version of the article
to compare it to the one that I read on my stream last night,
which was like the first draft of it prior to them adding these
updates. Again, updates, not corrections, additional info and
clarification, which happens all the time. And this is not a
stealth edit because you can clearly see what they have changed.
Um, so yeah, if you want to compare it, I can send you the archive
link to the old one. >> I send me No, could you send me
Is there an archive link for the new one that someone could create?
I'm having an issue with archive sites right now. For some reason,
they're just like straight >> breaking down for me,
>> but I'm trying to go and get this to like actually work
for me. I just love if uh stuff could just work, you know? Cool.
Archive site still not working, but I do want to see what was
edited and what was updated.
>> Do you have a by the way, do you have like a subscription
to Wired or where are you seeing that? >> Um,
it's not paywalled for me on just like the regular thing. It
was last night. Um, but today it's not paywalled. >> Oh,
hold on. It's paywalled because I've looked at it multiple times.
That's why. >> and I guess I can't close this. >> No,
no, no. Hold on.
>> I'm I'm fixing it. I'm fixing it. Give me a second,
guys. Give me a second.
>> We're doing a little trickery. Little tom foolery in
the background. Okay. Little tom foolery. That should work. If
that doesn't work, then I don't know. Oh, come on. You read your
last free. Come on. I different IP. I cleared all my local storage.
What are we doing here, guys?
Okay, I've got this one from 9:00.
This one worked for me suddenly. Okay,
I believe this is this should have been just recent that this
would have been >> Oh, I can share my screen. I'm a dumbass.
If you if you need to see it, >> hold on. What is the What
is the text? Oh, right here. Update
>> here. Following the publication of the article, Graeme
Wilson of the Elias Law Group, whose participation in a Zoom
call was reported upon, and who did not respond to Wire's pre-publication
and email requesting comment, reached out to Wired on several
points. These include whether members of the cohort can publicly
talk about working with Chorus and Chorus' connection to get
influence, both of which Wired has clarified.
>> Also, hold on. Don't know. >> Listen, boy. tread
careful with
the scandal talk
or you'll end up like a niche in a >> sorry AI voices kind
of going crazy right now. Thank you Moshi Liowitz
longtime donator to the channel. Thank you for your support.
Okay, it was an RFK voice. Yes, it up. It is what it is. Thank
you very much for the donation though. Okay, so
which was clarified. We've also included comment from Wilson
regarding courses place course placing restrictions on content
whether vspay was included in any of the course material. Okay.
Okay. So uh let's see here. Why did this just click onto something
else? Hello. I'm just looking for let's see uh politicians here.
I'm just looking through cers in the program must funnel all
bookings. So this didn't change at all. are not allowed to use
any funds or resources that they receive as a part of the program
to make content that supports or opposes any political candidate
or campaign without express authorization from Chorus in advance
and in writing per the contract. Contracts reviewed by Wired
prohibit standard partnership disclosures declaring that creators
will not publicize their relationship with Chorus or tell others
that they are members of the program without COR's prior express
consent. Screenshot from a slideshow that was shared with Wired
following this article's publication by Graham Wilson, a lawyer
working with Chorus that offers several talking points if a member
of the cohort wanted Oh, sorry. So, there's
is this describing what should be here? A screenshot from a slideshow
was shared with Wired following this. Okay, so this Graham Wilson
guy says, "Here's a screenshot. This is the clarification that
Brian Tyler Cohen talked about, I believe, guys. So talking points
if a member of the cohort wanted to discuss chorus publicly.
They also forbid creators from disclosing the identity of any
funer and give chorus the ability to force creators to remove
or correct content uh based solely on the organization's discretion
if that content was made at a chorus organized
So basically they were given ways to talk about it publicly.
Now what are these ways? And that still doesn't imply that there's
no control there, right
guys? We don't control whether or not you can talk about it.
We'll just give you the ways you can talk about it. And if you
do anything outside of that, well, I don't know. This says that
the screenshot would be here, but I can't tell if the screenshot
is here on the on the live article is the issue.
Do you have a screenshot down here, Aaron? >> Mm- No, I
don't think there's any pictures. I don't think they've shown
any materials that they privately reviewed for the prior to the
publication of this and even since the >> Interesting.
Okay. I would love force reached out post publications not single
correction or retraction in the story. So yeah they're even saying
that like okay apparently this became a contention later and
we gave like talking points on how to discuss being a part of
the program. Exactly.
So I would love to see those I would love to see those published.
Perhaps we'll find them on Twitter at some point soon. >> We
gave them talking points but again according to their own website
we discourage we encourage members. What was it? It's like non-binding
language that says like we ask members to respect each other's
privacy and like not name other members. Then this doesn't even
address the non-disparagement thing. >> The non-disparagement
thing, if I remember correctly, was something that was discussed
and done away with, right? >> Is it? Let me see. Non >> uh
in the group chat formed to discuss contract negotiations, some
creators discussed a clause prohibiting the disparagement of
other creators. not being able to criticize anyone else affiliated
with Chorus felt restricted to some according to text messages
posted in the chat. Eventually, the creators in the group chat
agreed to drop the issues they had. Now, that says that's a clause
that exists. >> How do we know it wasn't implemented? >> was
a suggestion. So, did they suggest it? Did the creators suggest
it themselves and then Chorus said no or was it suggested by
>> they discussed it? Some creators discussed it, but then
it says in the next paragraph, eventually the creators in the
group chat agreed to drop the issues they had. >> Yeah.
Uh, so I'm not totally sure. >> So, it's ambiguous to me.
I guess you can't really know. >> It is difficult to know.
Space Coast, thank you for the five gifted guys. Two subs away
from another two hours on the >> Get those two subs in.
>> Let's go.
>> Oh, I got one. Thank you. >> Uh, well, that's
what it looks like, Private Huff, but I I'd heard from somebody
that this was uh and discussed a clause. I don't know if this
is actually a clause that existed. It's unclear in the article
whether it is a clause. Maybe they don't know. Maybe they they're
saying it because it's only available. Maybe it's not in the
contracts they reviewed, but it is in the group chat and it's
discussed in the group chat. Other creators. Yeah, I don't h
this this is one of those things where it's like I feel like
I'm taking crazy pills. We had one to over here. We had um Is
it not Killinger? No, it's not Killinger. It's uh Kogan Style
82. Both of those guys are being are like on the same page. I
assume a lot of libs are on where it's just like, "Oh, this is
all lies."
And I really don't know that this this article for Taylor Loren's
is like it seems pretty solid. I've seen articles where I feel
like she's far more dishonest.
>> Although I wonder if I'd still think that in retrospect,
but I I feel like I've seen articles where I feel like she's
far more dishonest.
>> It's distorting for sure.
>> What What's it distorting one to >> people? Again,
they keep responding. The Tik Tocker did this. David Pacman did
this and I think Brian Tyler Cohen did They were like, "The DNC
has nothing to do with this. If you control F in the article,
DNC is mentioned exactly one time in reference to a creator that
they work with, Chorus works with, I can't remember if they're
actually part of the program or not, who runs an American Girl
doll pro DNC meme account. Very niche. That's the only mention
of the DNC right here in the in the title. Basically, Democratic
messaging and then uh $8,000 a month to push the party
>> right? That doesn't mean that they're like to to intimate
from that that the she's indicting or suggesting that the DNC
was behind this. One, why wouldn't she just say that? And two,
the Democratic establishment and the DNC are not synonymous.
I can see how maybe layman would take that or maybe make that
assumption, but I know that David Pacman, Brian Tyler Cohen,
and this liberal influencer on TikTok should know that there's
a distinction between that. Nancy Pelosi is the Democratic establishment.
Hakeem Jeffree Democratic establishment. They are not part of
the DNC. That's a completely separate >> Sure. So, I think
it's strange that Brian Tyler Cohen says there's no party line
here. It's like really? If one of your influencers made a pivot
and started and went from to from progressive to liberal to uh
centrist, unaligned to MAGA, you're telling me that you would
just continue to support them because there's no party line.
I doubt that. I seriously seriously doubt that. There probably
are some ideological prerequisites for people being in this club
or being in chorus,
>> Uh well, I think they say they have a progressive policy
agenda. I think there's something in here possibly in trouble
if you go against that policy agenda, right? I assume that's
why the policy agenda is >> well I couldn't find the chorus
policy
>> other than them being like we're pro-democracy which
is so vague. >> Yeah, I know. I don't know what it means
either. Yes, they're pro-democracy. I love that they're like
there's nothing to do. We're a nonpartisan organization. It's
in uh this lady, the Olivia Juliana. She's like we're a nonpartisan
organization. And then about 5 minutes later, she goes, "Uh,
also, if you're looking to join a a cohort or sorry, a uh a group
that's opposing Trump in every way, it's like I think they call
that the Democratic Party in a lot of like I understand you.
I understand how it's not a direct overlap, but come on.
I don't know why we have to I don't know why we have to do this."
Kilo says, "You guys are giving the average reader way too much
credit." No, I'm not. That's why I said I think the I can see
how a layman might have said that. But I think it's weird for
the creators that for Brian Tyler Cohen, David Pacman, and this
Tik Tok creator to respond to that criticism as though it is
really a reflection of what Taylor's article uh claims cuz David
Pacman says there's factual inaccuracies in this. And then he
says in the next sentence in his response, the DNC has nothing
to do with this. And I'm like, but she never claimed that the
DNC did cuz that would suggest based on how he ordered that the
DN that she said in that article somewhere that the DNC had something
to do with this. But she never alleges that. She never reports
that. She doesn't even talk to any creators who report that.
But I guess uh like you know, never Trumper or sorry, never Trump
Republicans can be in the progressive or because they're technically
prodemocracy still, right? >> Counter points. Counter points.
Um >> yeah, there's >> I'm trying to trying to get
this to load. Can anyone get this link to load? This link will
not load for me. I'm put in the chat right now.
Can anyone get that to load? That's the time stamp for Brian
Tyler Cohen on uh talking about basically like Democrat planning.
There might be a YouTube video on it. Hold on. Give me a second.
Oh, here we go. I finally got it to load
>> Brian Tyler Cohen comes and joins.
>> I think this is the combo I was thinking
>> but I'm not sure cuz uh in the schedule it doesn't say
pondering politics, so I'm not totally sure if he hops on there
or not. There was a conversation that did take place. I might
have to go and find it. >> Oh, I have one that someone
linked to me where he says Gaza is not my lane. Um,
>> well, I'm just looking at this cuz I could have sworn
when he says we're not aligned with the Democratic party. I could
have sworn when he hopped on with uh Josiah and Destiny at some
point. >> Yeah, I remember this and Josiah asks him about
his lighting, right?
>> Well, I that's what I thought happened. Yeah. Was like
something like that was basically they were uh they were having
this discussion. it was going on and then Josiah hops in and
they talk about how to plan out like Democrat messaging, how
to coordinate it. And so for me to go for when they go like there's
nothing to do. There's just no connection to the Democratic party.
It's like really
seriously if BTC goes on camera, it's this one. Okay, well there
he is. He's on camera. So I might I might check this out at some
point as well cuz I just think like this was around the time
November 15th, November 20th. Chorus is starting to form at this
point. I believe the other guy, the the black guy, this two raw
guy. Okay. November 20, 2024 is when he first posted about
>> So he first posted about chorus progressive creators
debut this thing. This is Brian Tyler Cohen's chorus. Okay, so
Brian Tyler Cohen knows exactly what he's talking about back
here in this video with Destiny. Okay, he's talking about Democrat
messaging and then he later says, "Oh, well this actually has
nothing to do with the Democrats." I linked to David Pacman's
announcement from 9 months ago where he announces that he's partnering
with Chorus, but he doesn't say if it's in a paid or unpaid capacity.
>> Well, that's what the two real guy did as well. Yeah,
>> I swear he also mentions the Democrats as well. Or maybe
he just says progressives or the left in America have never had
this. Um, and he doesn't say Democrats specifically,
but yeah, a lot of I mean, a lot of
I feel like so much of the heat that Taylor is getting is like
one of these because of the implication type things. I >> like
they just don't like the narrative surrounding like her the way
that she lays out uh
like the information that was disclosed to her with these
>> Well, and I think the I think part of the issue for
her is she's probably a part of like the cohort.
I think there's a real response that is probably going and being
aimed at like this
that would have been aimed at progressive victory or things tied
to like destiny people around him where they're like we need
to cut progressives out right I think there's a lot of like overlap
for somebody like Taylor Loren would see them as the same thing
and she probably sees that as an attack on like her politics
Hassan's politics cuz I know she mentions in the article Hassan's
not included in this right I think I think that's where she's
coming from with the article I think she is biased in the article
I think she does frame things a certain way I just don't think
it's like to say that she's lying.
>> Yeah, but everyone's biased. That's the thing. I told
Pisco I wish that he could like view and analyze the article
without knowing that she had written it cuz I wondered if it
would have any if that was having like any in like changing the
way that he was analyzing it, you know, >> like what do
you mean? Expand on that. >> That I I wish that people
uh so much of the discourse surrounding this article is not merely
about the claims within the article. It's again it's because
of the implication. It's because they don't like the narrative.
It's because they don't like Taylor Lauren and it's become like
deeply personalized to Taylor Loren. Like even in Brian Tyler
Cohen's response video again, he's alleging like she has taken
money from this. He's not really addressing like the central
claims made within the article. Nor do I think he really adequately
debunks them, but that's either here or there. I'm seeing a lot
of people just again like it's it's a skepticism that that this
could be factually accurate because it's Taylor Lauren. So, I
wish it had it could I could pretend like I could show this to
somebody be like, "Oh, it was written by John Jane Doe. What
do you think of this article, right?" And see what their analysis
of this article if they didn't know that it was written by Taylor
Loren and if it would be any different than what you know what
they do if they knowing that. >> Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Kilo
asks, "I don't know why you guys are acting like the article
isn't presented in a slightly dishonest way." I feel like that's
exactly what I'm saying. If you feel like I'm saying something
else, I'm saying it is slightly dishonest. It is framed to slant
against the people she sees is against her form of politics.
>> I just don't think it's outright lying. I just don't
think it's outright lying.
>> That's all. Yes, it is. Okay. So, Brian Tyler Cohen
and every single one of these people who said that Taylor Loren
engages in in collecting dark money in the same way as them.
Those people are all lying 100 times worse and you have a 100
times more heat for them, right? that they're all yelling or
sorry, they're all lying far more egregiously than she is, that
they're basically smearing her to the entire internet. We can
all agree that they are lying way worse than she is. I'm looking
at coconut. I'm looking at one to cover. We all agree that they
are lying far more egregiously than Taylor Loren is in
>> I'm not I'm not getting a response from these people.
Internet Ray, I that same question to you, buddy. Maybe I've
seen two Tik Tockers. Have you not watched Brian Tyler Cohen's
response? Have you not watched David Pacman's response? Have
you not watched a couple of these responses that all say the
same thing about her? Brian Tyler Cohen's response plays a 5-second
clip from the Candace Owens Tucker Carlson interview and says,
"Well, where Candace Owens goes, I kind of like Tyler Loren cuz
I think she actually voices her opinion." And Brian Tyler Cohen
goes, "I don't know about you, but I don't trust anybody who's
friends with Tucker Carlson and Candace
>> Oh man. >> Think of mild dishonesty. Yes, but
Kilo, like I think to me it looks really suspicious when they
do that. When they just egregiously lie in the other direction,
it looks very silly. >> Well, to me it's like if she's
being slightly dishonest, then just debunk it. >> Which
should be pretty easy. >> But instead, it's just like gay
joust
of like, well, no, she's the one who I'm saying she is lying,
so she has basically asserted this. I don't have to debunk something.
She has not proven it in the first place. But that's only going
to be more sus to people >> that don't have a stake in
it either way. Yeah, I would say the place where Taylor gets
caught, unfortunately for her, is right at the beginning when
she was sort of like editorializing and and trying to drive like
views for the article, right? But when she gets down to like
the hard claims, the hard claims are not dishonest in my opinion.
>> This is what I said about like the opening part, I'm
like, is this narrative? What did How did you just characterize
it? Do you think it's sensationalist or >> um editorializing,
right? It's like sensationalism would be the same thing. >> I
mean, is it that or is it providing context for the media environment
in which this this program is being created in the first place?
cuz only after the, you know, this this loss in 2024
>> is are are like you're hearing about the liberal Joe
Rogan and all of a sudden you have all of these different liberal
groups and private donors and and dark money groups that are
suddenly interested in like funding the online media apparatuses
to and like independent media apparatuses to catch up to what
the right-wing has been doing for a long long time.
>> It is Wait, I didn't even think about this argument.
It is a little funny that they're like, "Don't you understand
that the right-wing has been using dark money to fund people
and create the appearance of like organic engagement for years
and they spent millions of dollars doing it? We're creating our
group to fight that." And it's like, "Oh, so what are you doing?"
They're like, "We have classes." >> Hating it. >> We
have We have classes. We tell you how to like run a Tik Tok.
We tell you how to like crossbows from Tik Tok to YouTube shorts.
It's like that's how you're fighting. >> Tell you how to
get lighting like that. Too raw, too. That that is weird to me
that it's like how did why do you need you didn't know that you
need good lighting for your what? Like I would expect that the
mentorship would be like here's how to game the YouTube algorithm.
Here's what I found works as far as like all of this kind of
like nitty-gritty
little details and stuff surrounding like here's ideal upload
times. Here's what I've noticed when I spam a bunch of uploads
or here's what happens if I don't upload for two days. is like
it's going to be insight into like stuff that you couldn't know
unless you've been a successful YouTuber yourself, right? As
like kind of trade secrets. That's what I would assume the mentorship
would come from. But these people are talking about this person,
they helped me get a selfie stick. They told me to get this type
of ring light. And it's like, dude, there's tutorials for that
all over YouTube. You're telling me that's the mentorship program?
How is that useful? The most valuable thing that David Pacman
has to offer is not insight into his production setup. It's It's
again how his YouTube channel has been this successful for this
long. >> I just like watching my chat respond to you. Yep.
Just do what Aaron says. She knows best. God, it's so easy. Huh?
I don't think that's what she's saying. I think she's saying
obviously get a mic and do like the very very most basic things
required to show your >> think that if David Pacman said
>> he was going to be offering mentorships that you as
a viewer could purchase from him so you can become a successful
YouTuber and you uh you pay for this like a really really expensive
mentorship and a lot half of what he says is just be sure to
get a good quality camera be sure to get good >> Okay.
Also Nick's I got to read this. Nick Kayla asks isn't she being
more than dishonest? She is trying to tarnish their reputation
as if they have they are the left tenant media taking dark money
instead of Russian money. They are taking dark money and she's
actually incredibly specific about where the dark money is coming
from. The 1630 fund that funds a bunch of liberal things, right?
She's not being dishonest. She's being incredibly specific. I
don't understand how you could possibly say that it's like the
same implication when she is actually laying out exactly the
source of the funding.
I said that as well and Pisco said that people get the impression
that chorus is like this secret group and I'm like no she's specifically
talking about how people may may not realize when chorus is not
that popular to begin or like that like it's it's not that visible
or wellknown they're trying to get it on the map but for two
even if you knew about chorus you might not know that they're
partnering with this 1630 fund and it's functioning as potentially
like a shell company for this larger dark money group. So, they're
transparent to the point that they say that's one of our funders,
but it's like, okay, but who funds your funer? And then from
there, they don't have to disclose that because it's a type of
it's a it's a I can't remember what it's called, the 501, whatever,
where they don't have to say who's who's actually donating. >> Hold
on. I know this. It's a I think it's a car committee. I actually
think it's if I'm not mistaken, I think it's the same thing as
progressive victory. Almost the same thing. 501c3, 501c4.
>> Yeah. One's one you don't have to disclose, one you
do. I can't remember. like you don't have to disclose for either
one. There are other like corporations you can form where you
do have to disclose, but these ones aren't allowed to be like
explicitly partisan or explicitly political. And that's why they
have to say we're nonpartisan,
right? That's I promise you if you get a if you get a deck from
one of these people, it will say, okay, it will literally say
you have to say you're nonpartisan.
We are a nonpartisan organization. We are a nonpartisan organization.
We are a nonpartisan nonpolitical organization. Right? It'll
say it over and over and over again because if they if they are
anything else, they would be re regulated. They would get to
be regulated,
>> Okay, hold on. I'm uh what am I thinking of? I'm also
I'm probably going to go through guys. I don't know if we're
going to get to the kick house stuff. I will probably get to
it later. Okay, I promise. Cuz then I I'll leave it till later
anyway cuz Wes might come on. I want to keep going through this
stuff. I'm probably going to go through the loader box eventually.
I'm probably going to get through that eventually because um
I think he went and tracked down a bunch of this stuff as excuse
me as well. What do I have? >> I think a lot of people
are triggered that it's like oh so the second the democrat like
nobody cares when the rightwing does it but the second the Democrats
try to play catchup or whatever suddenly the you know the moral
police come in and you guys want to like put a stop to it. I
say it's drama like leftist circular firing squad is what David
Pacman called it. >> Yep. You know, and like again, Hassan
put it like, "Are we trying to create like blue Charlie Kirk?"
>> That is what they're trying to do, right? Blue Charlie
Kirk. That's like what they want, which is like fine, I guess.
But the whole point of Charlie Kirk, in case anybody doesn't
know, all right. I believe Charlie Kirk is taking a of a pack
money. And I believe Charlie Kirk is explicitly cutting out anybody
who is not pro- Israel from his movement. That is an explicit
move to to like coordinate and to cut certain opinions out of
the right-wing entirely. And if you don't understand that, that
is the goal. That is why Turning Point USA offers so much free
money and so much, right? That's yes, there's a reason the gropers
are banned from their events. There's a reason. There's a reason
for all of that stuff. Okay? There's a reason why uh anti-Israeli
sentiment or anti-Israel sentiment, anti-ionist sentiment has
never flourished in the Republican party.
So you can say you want to be like Blue TPUSA, but understand
that Blue TP USA is created with a specific goal in mind. Yes,
Joe, bro. Like they're losing control cuz Israel's actions have
become like untenable.
Yes, this is true. Um, what else? >> I also think that
like it's kind of inversely proportional. Like it can be you
can have shills and it can be really really effective, but the
more quote unquote effective and like overtly partisan and just
explicitly and only only goal is being like pro-democrat,
the uh
like the less that's going to correspond to your audience being
wellinformed or it being necessarily factually grounded because
the stated priority is now just overt partisanship and Dems's
winning at all costs instead of like the truth or informing the
public or being an independent news broadcaster who gives commentary
and crit criticism based off of like empirical reporting, you
know, like those two things are going to be intention with each
other. Like are you an activist channel or are you a newscaster,
an independent content like news commentator first and foremost?
>> The um
yeah, that's one thing. The the other thing I have like a way
simpler approach to this, okay? And I keep saying it over and
over again. All I want is to be told the truth by the people
who are like doing this kind of thing and they seem like totally
hellbent on never telling me the truth. So, when I know that
in your heart of hearts, your actual reason for this is you believe
the Republicans do this, you believe it's a massive problem,
and you can never win unless you're willing to use the same tactics
the Republicans do. Now, I I'm fine with that, but you have to
tell me that. You can't say I'm crazy for implying that there's
some ethical like uh lapses here that might occur. You can't
tell me I'm insane for that. You okay? Just say that you want
the ethical lapses.
>> Yeah. If you're like, "This is what it takes to win.
We got to fight fire with fire." Just say, "Okay, but you're
abandoning principles to do that." And also, I don't know that
you should call yourself independent anymore cuz now you're in
cahoots with somebody potentially that has editorial control
over some your content. Even if it's in like a very very small
way, you're just by definition not independent anymore, right?
And that's not the same as like I don't think taking a sponsorship
for a product that you disclose is the same as like, oh, you're
not entirely independent. you probably still can claim to be
independent media because unless that sponsorship that you enter
into with the product or service that you're promoting also has
been granted editorial control over what you say and think, then
I don't think that that's going to be influencing your content
cuz you're shilling for Magic Spoon cereal and you are disclosing
that. >> Yeah. One thing that I don't really get that you
just like said is so technically because of their tax status
and how they're kind of like allowed to do this without disclosing,
they're supposed to be non-political
and they're supposed so they say they're like nonpart or whatever
the [__] Weren't they saying something about being
against Trump earlier?
>> Or have I misheard that? >> They're pro They're
pro-democracy. You're allowed to be pro anti-Trump if you're
pro-democracy, right? Prodemocracy is not a partisan position.
They just love democracy. Okay. So, I'm guessing there's a ton
of like uh like moderate Republicans they've got, right?
that's what I said. Yes. Like, if you tally up the votes of all
the people who are in that that group, I'm guessing it's like
99 or 100% Camala Harris, >> Also, it depends on what kind
of nonprofit they are. Cuz if you're a C3, you can't endorse
any candidates. If you're a C4, you can, but there's more restrictions
and stuff like that.
>> Okay. like one includes like
like church organizations and like charities and and the other
one is like like Planned Parenthood is like a C4. >> Does
that extend also to individual political creators? Are they if
they go and do like an event that's like sponsored by this
um like organization? Are they also not allowed to explicitly
endorse the candidate
or is that part of the candid is that part of their where they're
allowed to say whatever the [__] they want
even if they're getting paid to be there by this organization.
I think that there's limited advocacy that you can do even for
the ones where it's supposed to be nonpartisan.
Like you can you can advocate for certain like policy issues,
but I I think that they do draw the line at saying that like
like it comes down to like how much time is dedicated to advocating
or like lobbying or being political.
Um because like like what they they want it to not be like the
sole purpose of that uh entity.
And how that's determined I'm sure I don't know. I just I I I
I I cannot believe that the FEC is going to have it where you
can have an or organization that is like nominally nonpartisan
and doesn't endorse either party, but then everybody that they
give money to is endorsing a particular candidate. That that
just seems like insane. There's no way the rules are written
that way. >> It's America. Why are you Why are you like
I I don't know about that. Corporations are people here, thickers,
they have rights. LLC's have rights. >> They really do.
>> True. True. >> That was how Pisco owned you. He
believes in the corporation's right to its individuality. Okay.
>> He was getting into like Scalia type arguments and defenses
of like Citizens United. It was strange. But that's a whole other
can of worms that I just was like it's it's not going to pursue
cuz like Scalia's argument is like well most LLC's and corporations
only are like run by like a couple of people. So if you say corporations
aren't aren't people, then you're depriving and disenfranchising
like millions of people if you do this potentially.
So you have to say that they're people view them with like constitutional
and first amendment protections. the thing that I was going to
earlier I guess going to like the fund and stuff like that. Um
cuz my understanding at least the way it would usually work.
Well, okay. So basically I'm coming from like how things work
in like academia. If you get a stipend that is primarily like
go that's just in your pocket, right? If you need specific funding
that's like given extra you've got like research grants you can
apply for but stipens that's just money in your pocket that's
for you.
Just going to say whether a PhD program isn't going to uh pay
you for a particular like report, a particular paper, a particular
study. They're going to pay for your entire course.
you know, they're not paying you for a particular research product,
but they are paying you with the expectation you're going to
do research. And if you suddenly just put out no papers, you're
going to get picked out your kicked out your program, right?
Or you're going to get you you're probably going to lose. >> But
that won't be because you misused your stipen. It would be because
you're in violation of a contract probably because you didn't
you had deliverables that you didn't actually turn in. >> Um
all but what I'm saying is all they're going to uh be paying
you for technically is the PhD thesis at the end. There's going
to be an expectation that you're going to produce papers along
the way. But that's not explicitly ruled out or or that's not
explicitly spelled out and that's not going to be laid out in
the stipen requirements. But if you don't deliver anything during
your study there and you just try and like oh you know dawdle
along and then provide your final thesis you're probably going
to get a kick of the backside like somewhere along the way. So
I just I but I'm saying that's where I'm coming from. But the
idea that you have to use your stipen in a particular way or
if you do use it in a particular way you have to disclose it
to them.
I that doesn't make any [__] sense to me because
as soon as a stipen goes into your account that's your money.
especially if it's like going to be used for like living expenses.
What's the How do they account for that?
>> Can you just seem to find a way your account? You've
got the 8K, but you've got like 3K from YouTube. And so if you
just use 3K to be able to go and speak to a a politician, >> is
that totally fine? You don't have to disclose any of that?
>> Well, there's a point in this article where it says
creators in the program are not allowed to use any funds or resources
that they receive as part of the program. I assuming this is
in reference to the stipend to make content. that supports or
opposes any political candidate or campaign without express authorization
from chorus in advance in writing per the contract. So I don't
know how funible this stipend is or if there's any restrictions
on the stipend like no more than uh like 30% maybe allocated
towards living expenses or towards any activities unrelated to
chorus entirely or if none of it's managed and it's just like
here's your 8K you can find however way you want to use it every
month you just have to tell us how you used it and maybe like
you could spend it all on
groceries and a shopping spree at the mall but then and that's
you wouldn't be in violation of your contract, but maybe they'd
stop working with you because they were like, "Okay, well, we
saw how they used the money and this is not how we really want
them to use the money." Kind of like this like soft power of
like
>> you know that they're they're expecting you to use the
siphon in a particular way and they know that you that you know
that and if you don't do that, you're not going to be a part
of the program much longer. >> Okay. Like maybe. But also,
I think this could have a lot to do with avoiding the actual
partisanship, saying like, okay, there's there are some requirements
for us maintaining a nonpartisan status with regards to our 501c4
or C3, whichever one they're doing. And this is actually to manage
that that you guys can't just all go do whatever you want and
like sh on a bunch of Republicans or or even just do like I guess
positive coverage on Democrats. Like we actually need to maintain
this and know where we're going coverage-wise.
Highly possible. ZX1 KO you if you've linked this for the fifth
time without me clicking on it and is not something I need to
see if it's just one of these spuring out again. If it's just
one of these the true story behind Democrat influencers caught
making 8K a month. What is this? Is this another one of these
just going oh actually I didn't change my content at all. So
this is totally fine cuz if that's what it is I'm going to be
annoyed. >> I didn't need to disclose the sponsorship that
that uh Crumble Cookies sponsored me. I like their cookies already.
I already ate them before that. you guys knew that. So, who cares
if I'm sponsored and don't disclose it. You can always justify
like not disclosing something by saying but it hasn't changed
anything or whatever. It's like if it has if it hasn't changed
it then there should be no issue with disclosing >> He
calls Taylor a
cool what a cool guy. Okay,
I need to Okay, I don't know if you guys are here for this. I
also need to finish this person's TikTok here and then I'm not
totally sure where we go from there until we get more information
released. Right. I don't know why this person felt comfortable
releasing part of the contract and is not willing to just release
the whole thing. Like >> I don't know why any of these
people won't just release the whole [__] thing. I
don't get it.
>> Well, I Okay. I think I know why
the uh why Chorus won't cuz I think I think basically if you
do a dry reading of Chorus's contracts, I think it's going to
line up entirely with what the Wired editors authorized Taylor
Loren to
That's my That's my suspicion. And there might be >> Why
not? Why didn't Taylor just release
>> I'm guessing she agreed not to as a part of receiving
it from people. I'm guessing they agreed not to. >> But
if it's all the same, this is See, this is what makes me think
that they're not all the same because I wonder if all of those
creators are paranoid that like, no, it could be traced back
to me. >> Maybe. But I don't know. I don't know that they'd
have a good idea of what the other creators have. Do you know
what I >> Yeah. No, they had this group chat, but did they
actually go and individually verify with all the creators that
ended up saying yes, like, "Hey, here's a copy of my contract.
I'll show you mine if you show me yours." type thing. That'll
be the only way. And even then, they could have these kind of
like weird like stealth designations on each individual creator's
contract to like know who's is whose, like an invisible ink type
thing, you know? Like we're going to send every single creator
like a unique PDF >> and it has like like the files or
the file name would tell us like whose it is or there's some
sort of watermark on it that only is visible or something like
that that only we know to look for. >> Hold on. I want
you to I want you to observe the replies to this David Pacman
tweet and and see how it perfectly encompasses all all sides.
Okay, David Pacman. After a recent wired hit piece now fully
debunked, false claims started circulating and sadly some people
chose to unsubscribe from my website membership, Substack, or
unfollowed on YouTube. That outcome is exactly what the author
was hoping for when they put out a misleading and inaccurate
article. If you want to support what I do, please consider subscribing.
Okay, David Pacman always makes himself out to be the biggest
victim in these situations. You remember when he went live was
like, "Guys, you're not watching enough. You're not subbing enough.
I can't afford to pay my employees anymore." >> Guys, we're
getting
the country.
>> It's worse than that. That sounds quite familiar, I
think. Uh, yeah, Taylor Rens put this on Twitter earlier. Take
a look at this.
>> Okay, real quick. I'm just going to go to the replies
really quick. >> Very similar. Okay, this is is that going
to be that basically setting himself up to this is him describing
or setting up a record of loss for defamation because I've heard
that theory as well that like hey I've lost so I'm setting this
up so if I want to sue for defamation later I can but just real
quick the three replies okay don't worry you have like eight
grand a month to make up for those lost subs lefty I recognize
this name debunked by who David Howling Newant are quickly rising
in the ranks okay possibly our favorite anti-semitic Twitter
Twitter account now. I'm going to say it actually. He's overtaken
Hayasaka Aryan. Okay. He is now our favorite anti-semitic account.
Possibly my favorite account in all of Twitter. Okay. And aristocracy
saying, "David, you need to sue now." These are like the three
prevailing opinions. Sorry, we just need a lib. We just need
a lib in here. Just going like, "You're right, David. These people
don't fight fair. Have to destroy America." That's the fourth
one. Okay. >> I sent you a list of all of his sponsors
on his website. He has a [__] ton of >> Yeah.
Okay. David Pacman sponsors.
He's got a lot of sponsors. Damn. I don't >> Like this
was like his only like income revenue stream or whatever. Even
though again he still hasn't disclosed if he's like taking money
from them or not. Um >> he is not. >> Oh, Grind News
Babel Incogn
>> Helix Magic Spoon
some VPN thing. people bringing up like a crypto scam that he
did one time, but it's not on there. >> By the way, this
is when they say like, "Oh, we we wanted them to engage with
like our thing in a certain way and we gave them talking points."
This is what I think they want to avoid, okay? They want to avoid
the chorus people. They want to avoid the appearance. You ever
see that Fox News like local newscast compilation where they
all have the exact same
>> They want to avoid that. That's what they want to avoid.
And they know that if they all have to say this is this is a
sponsored piece from Chorus that that's what's going to happen
to them, right? They're going to start getting mocked for all
having the same talking points, right? That's what's going to
happen. That's why I think why are sorry that's why I think Chorus
had the the clause in there saying do not disclose. They want
the appearance of organic engagement especially from the smaller
creators who are saying the same things. They want the appearance
of like organic hey we're just right. And I dude I I think they're
going to get like this. So Taylor saying the similar statements
creators are now putting out about our story.
So fully debunked and then this one Aaron Parnes because of a
recent wired hit piece that is now being debunked misinformation.
And you got what? John Favro doing it as well. Like this seems
so cooked to me. It makes me It makes me so like I don't know
man. It It's so weird. The wired piece is this. The wire piece
is wildly dishonest and I'm truly surprised they published it.
Say what was dishonest. >> So, I just linked to you what
the thing that you were referencing about the ads all like lining
up. >> Oh. Oh, you Okay, hold on. Yes, Sinclair requires
anchors to read script bashing fake news >> that's gone
viral this weekend. Just a little taste of what these promos
look >> The sharing of biased and false >> false
news has become all too common on social media.
David Pacman, Brian Tyler Cohen, the progressive brat. It's just
going to be like a lineup of all of these people who want to
say all the same. This >> that's what they're going to
look like
without checking first. Unfortunately,
their own personal lives
extremely dangerous to our democracy. >> I think you get
the
>> Josiah Luke Beasley. I have respect for Josiah and Luke
Beasley because they started their conspiracy as two guys who
just worked 90 hours a week on Okay, that's how they started
their conspiracy. Josiah, Luke Beasley, these guys actually just
worked really hard at like coming up with like they'd read all
the articles, they'd watch all the they'd come up with their
points, right? Like they actually put the work in to make people
respect their opinions. That's that's way different than just
taking a check to like kind of repeat some stuff on rapid response
days from Brian Tyler Cohen. All right. Yes. Luke worked for
Pac-Man and then I believe Josiah worked for Luke in a similar
way where where Luke was doing a bunch of [__] for
Pac-Man and eventually built his own channel up and I think Josiah
did the same thing where he was doing some research stuff for
Luke and then he built up his own channel on the side as >> The
the um the response that they're given to this uh this wired
piece like don't forget they're still in the contract, right?
Which means they they can't really talk about the inner workings
of of Chorus without actually checking in with them. And I I
I would I would bet money that Chorus has sent them some kind
of communication, some kind of email or something reminding them
that you are still [__] the contract. Okay, you can't
make any public statements. We know this like news bit thing
has just hit. But you know, you still can't say anything without
checking in with us. Did you watch the Taylor Loren video just
silk?
>> No, we didn't watch the full Taylor Loren's piece either
>> because the full one has a has like a uh insight into
how they helped them navigate a different controversy where they
used images of creators that they weren't authorized to use.
And apparently one of the me the communications that they sent
to their creators was be careful the media is reaching out to
our creators but they don't seem to have good intentions. So
be careful about talking to them or something. Let me see if
I can't find it in the video and link it to you like where it
is. >> All right. Thank you. Uh Ruben Ruben3 $3 donation
says John Favro should stick to making movies. Different guy.
Different different guy. Rub >> I thought it was a bit.
I I saw so many people saying that in your chat I assume it was
a bit. >> It is a bit. It's a bit. But I was still >> cuz
you never know. >> Yeah. Luke, Josiah, BTC, and Dpack content
all look the same and were shout out the same AI given the same
prompt. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. You're just totally
wrong. Just so you know, there's humans who identified that Brian
Tyler Cohen algorithm on YouTube and decided to like drift in
that and make tons of money off of it very in a very calculated
fashion. Okay, how do you think I noticed the yellow arrows,
okay? There's a big big YouTuber, big guy on YouTube pointed
out to me, okay, that hey, you know those little yellow arrows?
You should start using those. For some reason, people love that
[__] For some reason, the YouTube algorithm loves
the yellow arrow. You put a Trump face and a yellow arrow on
any dog piece of content, that's going to make you millions of
dollar. Okay. Tens of thousands of dollars. >> Okay. I
sent it to you just so just this part these like play the 3 minutes
and this it's time stamp directly to it. >> Yeah. Yeah.
But that's not AI guys. Just so you know, that's not AI. Oh,
should we watch >> Well, I might have to watch this. I
might have to watch this whole thing. We'll see. But we can watch
this first. So, this is just uh some insight here on how they
>> building the next era for online news. Uh, independent
online voices, building the next era for online conversation.
But donations made via that page did not go directly towards
the creators pictured. Multiple influencers featured on Chorus'
website were frustrated that they were included on the page and
used to solicit small dollar donations without their consent.
Progressive YouTuber and former Media Matters staffer Cat Abugaya,
who's running for Congress in Illinois, was pictured on Chorus's
website and included in fundraising decks without her approval.
She asked that her image and name be removed and no longer used
for fundraising and marketing purposes. When I asked Chorus about
this back in April, Chorus's co-founder, Brian Tyler Cohen, issued
a statement through his comm's director saying, quote, "Corus
came together quickly on a few Zoom calls with creators after
November, and we've been running at full sprint since then. As
a creator, I would never want to put another creator in a difficult
position for any reason." And we removed Cat when she asked.
Ali, >> that's not that's not the answer to that, is it?
Wait, you used her name to fund raise that I feel like that's
not how you just you just go, "Oh, yeah, we removed her when
that's you get caught doing a crime." You get caught like living
in somebody's house and they call the cops. You're like, "No,
no, no, no. I'm sorry. You asked me to leave. I'll be respectful
and leave."
No, >> he says like we were going too fast or something
like that at one point. No, wait. You have to keep going. You
have to keep going. I am the creator who was
below the donate button said that the company must have just
taken an image of her off social media. She said quote I did
not even know that I was on this website. I am not financially
tied to them at all. VSphere known as Under the Desk News who
has over 3.6 million followers on Tik Tok told me I'm not in
any collective at all. That's my problem with the way it went
down. I don't think anyone should be pitching me other than me.
What we need is for people to invest in independent media, and
that doesn't necessarily mean investing in a consulting group
that is going to become a middleman for independent media. Chorus's
effort to act as a bridge between creators and political leaders
ruffled the feathers of influencer management companies and talent
agencies as well, whose job it is to negotiate opportunities
for their talent. Representatives for bigname creators told me
that they felt like Chorus was luring their clients with promises
of access to political leaders. quote, "Then they go to a bunch
of donors who don't know anything about the creator space except
that we need a left-wing Joe Rogan and they raise money from
>> Is there anything more independent media than a Blue
Yeti, guys? Who did this stock footage? What a legend plugging
in a Blue Yeti, making sure that USB comes unplugged and disables
their mic halfway through an interview. Oh, I can just I can
see that. >> These are dollars that belong to the creators,
the marketer said. Another representative at a major Hollywood
agency who asked to remain anonymous told me that Chorus quote
has no respect for how the entertainment industry works. They
think they're smarter than the agents and the agencies. You can
get away with that in the short term, but they're going to get
the party black ballalled. There are only so many times that
agents will allow some middleman to take ad dollars from our
entertainers before they're like, "F these people." And they're
getting very close to that. after I reached out to Chorus for
comment about all of this back. >> So, this is uh Wait,
the creators don't give money to Chorus? No, no, no. The the
Chorus had there's a couple different functions of Chorus. One
thing they were doing is they're raising money for their overall
operations using influencers that they didn't actually have access
to or hadn't gotten from. So, that's one of them. Okay. It's
not an MLM. No. And then they have a different program that's
a pilot program for small creators where they do pay them a stipend.
These are like different things. This is a different controversy
that that Taylor's talking about here that happened in April.
>> And Taylor believes that by them presenting
like photos and images of different influencers that they may
or may not work with on the same page as like a donation tab
that it gives a false impression to anybody who views the website
that oh, if I donate to this organization, it goes like directly
into the pockets of some of these creators. I personally disagree.
I feel like it's trivially obvious that if you're interfacing
with the website of an organization and they're like look at
who we work with that like in a roundabout way it goes back to
them like you're giving money to the organization which enables
them to continue doing the work that they're doing which will
inevitably end up probably as resources that they can use or
maybe even directly paid to them but if you want to donate to
a specific creator like the only way you can guarantee that is
by going just directly to their page and donating to >> Yeah.
So I would say it's totally fine for them to fund raise. I don't
think that's weird. Unless it's somebody they have no affiliation
with. If it's somebody they have no affiliation with, then there
there is some implication that it helps them in a roundabout
way. And if you don't have any affiliation, that's [__]
nuts to use their >> And they didn't just use her photo.
They used cat's like they put her like contact information as
well. >> Does she does she wait does she have no affiliation
or did she have no financial
>> No affiliation.
>> And they said, "Oh, sorry. Like we like did a meeting
or like pulled her in. We must have thought that she had like
said yes or something like that. I don't know. And then they
said like we were going so fast that like we included her. We
didn't mean to do that.
>> Little odd. Little odd. Um I'm going to let this play.
Give me 60 seconds. I'll be right back. Uh yeah, I'll be right
>> Back in April, Chorus sent an email blast out to the
creators in their network reading, quote, "Some reporters are
reaching out to creators about Chorus, and it seems with not
great intentions." To me, this set off immediate red flags. As
a journalist, anytime you reach out for comment about something
and the company or organization immediately starts smearing you,
especially when they're badmouthing you to people who have nothing
to do with the story, claiming that you have not great intentions,
you know that there's more to that story. Let me just also say
that claiming journalists whose job it is to challenge power,
investigate wrongdoing, and report on news happening on their
beats have some sort of bad intentions is really poor form. The
job of a journalist is to be annoying. It's to piss people off.
>> Okay. So, that is what you're talking about, right,
Erin? That piece right there where she's saying that
>> they're like, "Careful, media is reaching out. Don't
know if you want to actually comment on that." >> Yeah.
which, you know, depending on your perspective on the media,
you can see as a company doing their due diligence to help inform
them how to like engage with the media and not not fall victim
to like, you know, I guess being part of like a hit piece or
something. Or you can see it as like the way that Taylor does,
which is that they should not be trying to paint the media as
like out to get them or bad faith or nefarious when they're simply
asking for comment on a story. Just depends. And there's so many
other factors, too, cuz it's like, well, what outlet is reaching
out? Did they say what the story was? Were they just like, will
you comment on this specific thing? Will you comment in the capacity
of being a chorus creator? Like it would just depend. >> I
I have to go back. Hold on. Let me let me see this. So she showed
like communications here. I was away from my
>> Some reporters are reaching out to creators about chorus
and it seems not with great intentions.
I could see that coming about. I guess it would be depend on
what was going on there, right? What was what the reach out looked
like?
>> Yeah. And what art like what outlets were they affiliated
with? Did they did they give the subject of the article? Um,
I mean, but there's no shortage of people that have been interviewed
by the times and even reputable news outlets and they were like,
"Oh, I didn't realize that that was what the story was about.
They didn't tell me. I didn't know I was lending my voice or
my commentary to this particular narrative. I probably wouldn't
have participated." Like even Contra Points has talked about
in one of her videos how like she talked about like JK Rowling
being like transphobic or a turf, but she didn't realize that
the angle that they were coming at it was to like say that she
had been like a witch like on a witch hunt and say that like
oh JK Rowling is a real victim. And Kra was like well if I had
known that that was the angle I wouldn't have participated. >> Oh
man, did you guys uh check out this article? I feel like I had
it up. I'm not sure if I ever went and looked at it. Midas touch
turns Democrats minds to slop. Oh, I've I've watched this. And
there's also a YouTube video if you don't want to read it where
Nathan J. Robinson literally just reads out the whole thing >> and
it's called the same thing >> in his little bow tie with
a little microphone that he holds up in his uh fancy boy accent.
He has fancy light >> That guy is the most like bullied
in high school person like phenotype I've ever seen in my entire
life. >> It's like it's crazy.
>> If you control F email,
uh the juiciest part of that article that's recirculating will
will come up. It talks about Brian Tyler Co and David Pacman
being invited to the White House and that internal email.
>> Yes, they don't really talk about Gaza. >> Yeah,
this is the one where I realized that um this is probably the
actual content creator thing where they started talking about
chorus, right? Cuz they I think Brian says we started talking
about this at like a thing we got invited to or maybe Dave Pacman
says >> I don't remember Chorus being mentioned in this
Coron affairs article. >> Maybe maybe not. March last March,
huh? Oh, but that kind of lines up with are wait is that a different
thing than Brian Tyler Cohen saying it's not my lane because
that kind of lines up with we don't talk about Gaza. kind of
lines up with well that's not my lane
>> well David Pacman said we don't talk about it but he's
saying he's relaying that they had all agreed all the creators
that he met up with had kind of all mutually agreed like oh yeah
I don't talk about that either because it just generates controversy
and there's no point and every single time David Pman has ever
made commentary on Gaza even and Israel Palestine even before
October 7th he always would caveat it with like I will this issue
is toxic I will make no one happy I will always inevitably piss
off everyone I am going to get hate just by saying this. And
he always he does the I don't like Lakood. Nanyahu is bad. I
disavow the rockets. I disavow settlements need to stop. Two-state
solution. That's always what he says. >> I just realized
that uh Ryan Tara Cohen, Dave Pacman, Luke Beasley, and Lindy
Lee, your favorite Lindy Lee. >> Lind the lovely Lindy
Lee. Folks,
One of Good Influenc's featured influencers, Kenny Walden, who
goes by the name too real, too raw, too real, sorry, online has
taken his loyalty to the Democratic establishment even to to
even more grotesque extremes, hurling vile misogynistic attacks
at progressive lawmakers like Rashida Talib and bro, what he
wasn't there, right? No, this is about good influence and [__]
as well. But I just I find this funny that um this stuff seems
all connected and the the idea of like some of these people being
on the like don't talk about Gaza thing. I feel like I've seen
that exact uh opinion from some people that like do the exact
if you're like in this algorithm which I trust me okay I can
throw this out and I can feel totally confident saying this I
have total respect for Josiah okay I've heard he's told me about
like how he built his channel and how hard he had to work to
do it and I have like so much respect for that okay and how he
informs himself on domestic politics but I think he's in this
exact same algorithm he's like talked to or been close to a bunch
of these creators And I feel like that's his exact response on
it, right? Not my lane. I don't care about it. I'm not going
to talk about it. >> He doesn't say Gaza specifically.
He says foreign policy cuz I've asked him why he doesn't. And
he's like, "If you go on my channel, there's like almost no videos
about foreign policy cuz I don't know anything about it and I
don't care to do the work to know about it." So I can have an
informed opinion and nobody like people come to my channel for
my takes on the domestic affairs anyway. So I don't really bring
it up. >> But it's just I find that very interesting that
um I don't know that that's uh like a joint line basically from
a lot of these people. I just find that very interesting. >> Somebody
putting I it's like kind of common sense like they're just saying
the quiet part out loud that like yeah if you talk about this
it generates controversy especially if you're prodem uh it doesn't
look it like what was there to say you know
post October 7th when uh >> Israel killed like what like
10,000 civilians in like a month
>> 30,000 like by the end of like like less than six months
or whatever. What are you supposed to say?
uh lowest civilian to com combatant death ratio
>> of any modern urban combat most moral army on earth
okay
just saying I'm just saying >> John Spencer is that that's
his favorite lie the you know it's usually 9 to1 >> it's
actually really good that Israel's only done this to that even
though Israel is now admitting that like by their own data like
yeah 83% of who we've killed the civilians by the way >> whenever
you looked into this I just totally like interpreted the uh the
Gaza or like Palestine line as like coming from Taylor Loren's
and that was like one of her I guess theories or like speculation
about what this group like might be up to. Um
there's no way that they would intentionally exclude people based
on like choosing to talk about like Palestine, right? >> I
think I think they would actually explicitly include some people
doing it. I think they would actually explicitly do that because
Democratic comedian that you dunked on apparently got like a
cringy response. I went on her Instagram and she's talked about
Palestine. So, but here's the thing. >> This one, >> uh,
no, no, no. The one who is a comedian. Hold on, give me a second.
If I put comedian, this uh, >> sorry, you're saying it's
a woman and a comedian. Okay. Okay. >> Yes. A democratic
comedian and content creator on Instagram is how Taylor Lorenz
describes her. You go on her Instagram. What? I don't have your
stream open, so I don't know what you're up to. >> I'll
say what Jay Stalk can't. All right. She looks like a comedian.
There we go. >> Oh, you have the trick open. >> No.
Uh,
Cherry just yelled, "Women are funny. Women are comedians." Okay.
>> We love women. >> That's insane enthusiasm. That's
insane.
We love women.
>> How could I hate women? Women. I I am a woman. So,
>> okay. I want to If we If we finish this,
I Is she going to say anything else? cuz this is her debunking
right we were going through here debunking >> just that
could do it too accidentally I feel awkward but like anybody
>> so she basically said okay >> other means right
>> it's like not that big I think these arguments are pretty
close I think oh I was going to say the other part I had one
other point to make here with some of these things is I think
the thing that makes the wired article also look a little worse
is I think they take quotes in some cases
and they take like quotes or you know testimony from people but
those people are like super soy progressive types who are just
kind of like blowing things out of proportion a little bit and
I think some of that
article too. >> Yeah, I think it's some of it like seeps
into the article a bit. So >> Well, I think so long as
I don't know what question she asked him. So if she asked him
a leading question like do you feel that this is predatory that
should not have been asked in the first place nor included in
this because there's literally no journalistic value because
you've tainted the response by presenting a leading question
to your subject. But if he volunteered that assessment without
her prompting him to, then I think it's okay to include it. He
says he would never uh what is it? What did he say? Was not invited
to be part of the program, but believes that the way it was structured
seemed quote unquote predatory. He says that he would never agree
to take part in a program that was run in secret or wouldn't
allow him to disclose funding. What I don't understand is why
wouldn't you just donate to creators directly who have already
built something and just need to put gasoline on the fire, says
Edwards. Dems at least understand that the internet exists now,
so that's good. But they still think influencers are just there
to do a terrible directive camera interview that no one watches
rather than just treating us like another form of media. Well,
because I think they kind of want to like co-op this. No. >> that
that's the thing. >> There's an answer to his question
that's trivially obvious. >> They know they could do that.
They are choosing not to do that. >> Yeah. I think um I
think Democrats are misunderstanding how the like Republican
movement was built and why it was built, right? like that it's
it's from a significant amount of deplatforming and that it was
built up organically on like doing the things that could travel
via word of mouth. It's why it's like basically totally overrun
by populist populism now, right? >> Kind of.
>> I think I think it's a lot of bottom up control, a lot
of audience capture versus Democrats are seeking like top down
control. And I think they're looking at how Republicans got Joe
Rogan and other people and that's through bottom up. Like their
audience is saying, "Oh, you should talk to >> you more
though >> because think Dave Rubin. How did Dave Rubin
start the Ruben report? You think that he just had seed money
lying around so he could [__] break away from TYT
and do that?" No, he had coke feather money. >> Yeah, but
Dave Rubin's a loser and he's not popular anymore. >> He
is, but in 2016 he was not a loser.
>> Sure, but like that's like >> I feel like that's
a different aspect. I feel like that's you could do the same
thing with the Daily Wire, right? Like the Daily Wire to me is
not emblematic of any of these issues. >> The failing Daily
Wire,
>> they're struggling. >> Daily Wire is failing.
>> Yeah. They've been failing >> cuz they they up
trying to do like the movies and and like expand to like children's
entertainment and media, but like why are you going to watch
like a bootleg version of Bluey?
They up trying to co-opt talking points from populists when not
understanding like populists at all while being like straight
up neocon shills like like basically Ben Shapiro is and and just
not understanding that they were programming their audience to
walk away from them the second they started trying to do the
tow the party line thing. >> I think a lot of it happened
over Israel. Like I think I've I've said this for a long time.
I think they basically took Nick Fuentes's talking points. They
stripped any anti-semitism out of them and then they fed them
to their audience, right? And they did that for long enough.
>> And then there's something there. There's something
there that you don't understand that he does. I don't know if
you've seen his numbers recently. Like he's doing like hundreds
of millions of views a week on on Twitter just from his
>> Yeah. His clips are going bonkers. He's getting like
thousands of dollars in donations a day. I think he just upped
his minimum superbucks.
>> But he's been debanked just still. That's not true.
Oh, he's been debbanked.
I hear people repeat that lie all the time. He has not been debbanked.
There's no evidence that he's been debunked. The There's only
evidence that processing payment platforms do not want to hostess
it, which means like Venmo, Cash App, PayPal, like they won't
work with him. >> Sure, sure. Sure. >> There's no
evidence that he's been debanked, though. >> I think enough
of that happening turns into something equivalent to debanking.
I think when you can't use major payment processors is pretty
rough. But um >> he found
I think he was kicked out of like certain banks though. I think
he had his accounts closed. But that's not >> Yeah. The
Fed the Feds audited him because he randomly got over $600,000
in Bitcoin. Okay. Okay. >> I'm talking about he actually
was kicked out of a bank. Like his account actually was closed.
>> How reliable are the X engagement numbers though?
>> Uh they're reliable enough. I'm not I'm not even I'm
saying his donations through the Rumble platform are like insane,
too. Like he gets just super chats through Rumble and makes like
a shitload of money from them. Like he's making insane amounts
of money now. >> Bank of America did close his account.
Rook 77. If you have a article or anything that's proof that's
not just Nick Fentes saying that's the case, I would love to
see it cuz I could not find it. I spent hours trying to find
a letter, right? >> He's shown letters where I couldn't
I couldn't find it. I could only I found a WhatsApp screenshot
message from him saying add that to this platform that's already
like you know deplatform me or something like that. What would
be the big distinction there though if he's been like rejected
or shut down by payment processors versus actually having like
bank accounts shut down
>> when I hear like debanked I'm thinking like just like
you know like like kicked out of like financial institutions
I guess like they would >> bank has much different financial
obligations to its uh clients than like PayPal does which is
why everybody dunked on Xander Hall when they thought that he
was using PayPal as his bank account cuz they recognized that
there is a critical difference even though they are tangentially
related cuz like if there's fraud on my bank or whatever like
they have to do something if there's fraud with PayPal they may
or may not do something depending on how it >> Yeah. Yeah.
I the only thing I can find first like couple uh instances are
people saying that yeah they held for 6 months Bank of America
froze the ship for 6 months following the giant >> and
post January 6th and post that you could also argue that there's
a liability concern for the businesses because he is involved
in domestic terrorism. you know, if you're at January 6, if you're
inciting that or whatever and that he's a liability, or you could
also say that that's just post talk rationalization. They just
don't want to do business with him. >> Can you say that
if he wasn't charged? >> Uh, he was, wasn't he charged?
He was subpoenaed and he had to give a >> Hey, he wasn't
charged. >> Nick Fuentes charged for January. >> I
feel likely
wasn't charged, right? >> Sorry, just so I didn't know
that you're the resident Fuentes expert here. I just I should
defer to you. I shouldn't >> Thank you. Thank you. Hold
on. Uh, I should have a clip for this. >> I know everyone's
watching Fes though. I know every single MAGA conservative who
has access to a X account or a Twitter account, whatever. If
I'm getting America First on my feed every now and then, and
I'm clearly not a conservative, they're getting it every other
post then and they just pretend like they're not.
>> They'll they'll watch him. >> No, Eirl never.
>> That if I was faster, I would have had that ready when
you first said I was the expert. But >> there you go. >> Not
fast. >> He was in charge. That's why everyone thinks he's
a Fed. Oh, okay. So, that makes sense. That makes sense. >> Uh,
in 2022, Bank of America closed my checking account and my credit
cards without any explanation. Bank of America is lying. This
is a clear ev this is clear evidence of politically motivated
debanking. How is this legal in America? And it's a letter to
him. We made the decision to close your personal checking/savings
account. I feel like
pretty much like proof.
You could say you don't trust it because he's posting it. But
>> Nicholas, I for I didn't even know that he had his account
restored. Um, let me see. Think of >> Dingolingas. Destiny
has been charged with Is it fair to say he has any? Yes, but
that's different because we had Destiny say that he had materials
from this girl and then her age was conclusively proven around
the like around the time frame of when he had those materials.
That's way different. That's way different. Okay. That's like
he admitted to having and didn't know the age and then once he
found out the age we know what the is. Okay. >> Okay. So
he was debanked but do we know that he says this is clear evidence
of politically motivated debanking? That that's the part that
I don't know that he substantiated here. >> Um yeah I don't
think he has either. Sure. Sure. Sure. Sure. >> Isn't being
against insurrection like kind of political if you think about
it? >> Against insurrection? Sure. Are you talking about
again with the nonpartisan nonpolitical leaning of the group?
No, that's what my fun is. Sorry. >> Oh, I see. I see.
>> Are you saying that like if the reason why they did
it was on the basis that he was president on January 6th and
that if they're taking the stance that okay, we're in opposition
to anybody who participated in an insurrection that that constitutes
like politically >> I I I was meing I I'm worried you think
I'm a now. I'm like a I'm like a moderate left kind of Libby
guy.
>> Um
I'm sorry to this point. Jayto's the only grouper here. >> Okay,
you didn't even say it right. Okay, grouper. Are you serious?
>> Listen, I'm that detached from the far right. That's
that's just how libby I am, you know.
>> Grouper. Grouper. What is it? What? >> J, did
you used to be a groper or are you still a groper? >> Uh,
that's a disingenuously framed >> Just look at his head
is like, don't sound defensive. Don't sound defensive.
I could say I can't just say no cuz if I say no then he implies
that I was one >> that you're it's a tricky question. >> No,
it's not tricky. You were never a
>> That is true. I could have said that but having to like
take answer this question under advisement. Jesus Christ. It's
not looking good.
>> Listen, I've got a couple >> Stop showing your
leftist card to hit on
>> I've got a couple gropers in my audience and I don't
want to upset them. Okay. I'm not even a leftist.
I love capitalism. >> He's a grouper or not a grouper.
Whatever we determined
the fact that >> he's actually still not [__]
>> I do not want to find out in 3 years that you are a
racist. >> I'm not a racist.
>> That's just what's important to me right >> Okay.
Yeah, I'm not racist.
>> Are you a
>> Okay. Holding you. A curious person would wonder why
I could answer that one so quickly and not the racist one so
quickly, but it's fine. Anyway, >> oh, that reminds me
when you read the David Pacman thing that the tweet where he's
like totally debunked, by the way, which again kind of reminds
me of Trump if he was like able to to sound more articulate.
Uh, I wanted you to try to read it in David Pacman's voice. You
should get an like a TTS or like an AI thing of him. It would
be funny. I think that David Pacman is so unintentionally hilarious
with his like deadpan >> He can be funny. I it's it can
be weird because he's also got a weird like way of describing
things. Like he'll describe people he's like friends with, has
close personal interactions with as if he doesn't know them at
all all the time. Like, oh, what did he just do? Oh, he says
like
Twitch streamer Hassan [__] who seems to be like
this. It's like, bro, I've seen a picture of you at like birthday
party with Tan [__] Like, I know you know him. >> Mick
Fuentes $25. >> I have it on good authority. My main man
JSTLK is my top dono. best racist and best enjoyer of children.
>> I don't have the money to be his top dono. That's not
true. None of that's true. Okay. That's not None of that's true.
None of that is true. That's all
>> Did you see him make fun of Tucker? >> Uh Nick.
Yeah, we covered all of that. Nick fun of Tucker.
>> I don't even know why I doubted that. Of course, you
covered all of it.
>> Yeah. Well, it's just funny when when like Tucker is
like in a totally disingenuous way somehow is like, "Yeah, Nick
Funto said my dad was in the CIA. I didn't even know that. I
didn't even know." It's like,
are you or And then you find out that there's a bunch of clips
of him talking about his dad being involved with the CIA from
like years ago. It's like, why are you lying about that? That's
the weirdest thing to lie about that Nick Fuentes broke to you
that your dad was in the CIA and you only found out after >> because
he knows his audience is not going to go bother to check it.
>> It was crazy. It was It was like It was absurd.
Face cam when? Uh maybe. Maybe soon. I'm not totally sure. We'll
see. >> And also that like makes it believable to people
cuz they were like he would like you know if you if you rebut
a lie like that that confidently it's like well he wouldn't just
say that if that weren't true. If it were actually true, he wouldn't
confidently say that he's never said that before. He only recently
learned of it. So, people are more likely to take you at your
word the more insane the lie is honestly than like a smaller
lie.
>> I do I do have a problem with assuming people are being
like like honest, I guess. I just thought that he was like memeing
like whoa, I never knew that. What? Whoa, my dad was in the CIA.
Huh? I thought that that's what he was doing. Was he actually
trying to deny that his dad was in the CIA or affiliated with
>> He was trying to deny that he knew until after he died,
even though there's video spanning back decades where he talked
about this and that he knew it.
>> He he said, "Come to find out, you know, my dad passed
away. Come to find out, >> he was involved with the CIA."
It's like he didn't say it in a way that like really the delivery
implied he was joking at all.
>> yeah. I don't I don't think so. Give me a second. I'm
just going to check. >> And he was like, why would I lie
about
>> And Candace isn't going to push back and no one in his
audience is going to bother to check. I >> I I don't I
thought Candace Owens would be like dead
like in terms of popularity within the >> Um why >> she
got kicked out the like Daily Wire. I thought she was cooked
after that. >> No, that's cool to these people cuz she
immediately pivoted to like uh Yeah. She's She's like the only
one not cut by Israel. Yeah, I don't know. >> And also
Ben Shapiro had to protect like you know these free speech absolutists
we we allow ideological diversity had to explain and acknowledge
like okay clearly there is an Overton window within the Daily
Wire and Candace Owens fell outside of it and so that's why she's
gone right that's why she said Kender cuz she didn't tow the
line on certain issues and she also had beef with Beniro so
>> she was like let go but she was trying to fired in my
opinion >> she was doing a tech tone yeah >> but
I was saying like what what audience what audience is she playing
to like she's populist conspiracy theorists.
>> Yep. She's Christian like Nick Fuentes and he's looked
up like all of that area, right? >> I mean, if you trust
Nick at all, she's just like literally an industry plan. >> Hello
again. >> Hold on. I got a donation. One second. >> You
are my 14th best donator. >> Okay. Thank you for the $14.88.
Nick Fuentes, could you chill with the dono money? I don't know
what the weird Thank you for the money. I appreciate the almost
$15.
Candace Owens, if you believe Fuentes, he says she's like an
industry plant. She's got like a billionaire husband, right?
There's no reason for her to be doing this. >> No, he's
not.
>> No. Candace, >> that husband of hers is not a
billionaire husband, is he? >> Oh, multi multi-millionaire.
>> Former chairman of Turning Point UK, former CEO of Parlor
and Parliament Technologies, the son of Michael Farmer, Bacon
Farmer, as well as husbands of the Okay. Were these like is he
like the heir to fortune? >> Yeah, he's literally a lord.
Okay. >> That's how she knew um Andrew Tate like before
he popped off, right? Met him through her husband. >> Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. >> I mean, yeah. I I don't really Nick Fuentes
has got like a lot of reason not to like Candace Owens, so I
don't know.
>> But I cuz Okay, the thing is about like Candace Owens
audience is she's more far right than Daily Wire. Such as she's
like butting heads with them. She's
more moderate than Nick Fuentes and like kind of disavows him
or whatever the [__] Where the does that put her?
>> She's like a paleocon. >> Yeah, but less of a
paleocon than Nick Fuentes. Like I'm talking in terms of like
audiences that she's like trying to gun for. >> Yeah, cuz
she's not like an outright >> Also, just real real quick,
I'll I'll answer ask the question again, but George Farmer's
dad estimated net worth in 2022 150 million.
So, not a billionaire, but absolutely set for life in every possible
way. >> Uh, or to the extent that she is a she's more pragmatic
than Nick because she was trying to be like I watched that interview
um on my own time to see if it was even worth reacting to on
stream. I didn't think it was, but she was like, "Why don't you
just cynically use uh Jews like Dave Smith? Aren't they useful
idiots?" Basically, like you're stupid to not do this. Um,
and he was like, "Yeah, no." He was I guess being the more consistent
because he's like I'm not collabing with you. >> She doesn't
give me like vibes. I Okay, maybe maybe you're going to think
this is like a really small like insignificant dist distinction.
Like >> I don't know. But like she she gives me the vibes
of like hardcore Christian
>> For sure.
Christians have a long history of being anti-semitic as [__]
I get hardcore um hardcore pure grifting vibes and she sees the
like conspiracy populace right as the most naive she could rearm
from. >> Piers Morgan $300,000
that she would be vindicated that uh Mcronone's wife is actually
a man. >> Maybe I I would just wonder if she has proof
of that. Why does she spend hours and hours? >> She says
that she doesn't she says it's going to come out in discovery.
>> Yeah, she I like she's literally herself. She's like,
>> I was there to disprove it of that documentary. It's
so stupid. She just has no evidence at all. She's like, "Yeah,
there's like that hang around these people." Like, if you go
to like three levels of connections deep, there's like around.
It's like, "Okay,
>> I mean, I really think that they should not they shouldn't
be suing her. They should just be saying she's actually a white
person that's painted black all the time and get her to disprove
it. >> Okay. It's like that would be the only way to demonstrate
how absurd what she's doing is and how unfalsifiable it is because
every single bit of information that they present to attempt
to to prove it's still never enough. She's like, "No, I literally
need to see footage of her actually giving birth and like a baby
coming out of her birth canal. How come that doesn't exist?"
>> Well, I think she said something like, "Oh, if you could
show me," originally she was saying, "If you just show me pictures
of her as a as a kid, I would accept that." And I like, "Oh,
that's actually like her brother. That's not her." Or something.
Uh,
>> so again, like everything that you present, it's just
like that's a lie. That's part of it. You're being duped. They
are that's not true. They that's fabricated. They just say that.
You can't disprove it. >> Okay. Hold on a second. We got
a Jake Shieldswuite here hanging out with Dave Smith from August
25th and he responds to this for some fight back podcast. This
podcast. Okay. People are angry. I'm with Dave Smith because
he's a Jew. Dave and I Dave and I I assume have a few differences
in our beliefs. But Dave has fought harder than almost anyone
for the people of Palestine. Hey Dave, with a passion for being
a race trader, why attack a man on our side?
Dave Smith just sitting here smiling. Okay, our only difference
is
I get a thumbs up, Dave. You want to smile at the camera for
me, Dave? Only difference we Hitler that Jake Shields replied
to a Hinkle tweet where it's like a photo of Netanyahu like half
of his face and the other half is here.
And Jake Shields is like, "What the bro? He like defeated these
people. Don't compare him to that."
>> And the the caption was just a screenshot of that interaction
and somebody put like ideological and they say there's no ideological
diversity on the right or something like that.
>> Dude, what happened to Jackson Hinkle? That guy like
fell off the map.
>> No, he didn't. >> Do we Do we know what happened?
>> Not in the same circle. Oh, he's he's during his circles
though. >> No, I I guess he's just super far lefties would
hear about him, see him. I just don't see anything to do with
Jackson Hinkle anymore, guys. Gone in my world. Stop >> he
was adding somebody and he was like debate me that Stalin is
like the best thing ever,
>> dude. Hos
is awesome. When when Hos is online, I raid him on kick cuz Hos
streamed on kick when nobody was streaming on kick. So, whenever
Hos was online, I'd ra him immediately. Like if I was ending
stream cuz H is funny as [__] Okay. >> No,
but Hans is funny as Okay. I am a >> There are only two.
Dude, >> there are only two. I I should have that clip
like always ready. >> Where's his like [__]
Let me look him up on kick. Give me a second. I need this. I
need my clip. I've got like a clip of him and he's just got an
AK and it's an awesome clip. Give me a second. I mean, I just
pull up his I pull up his clips from last week and he already
looks so cool. Okay, just this is like last week. He already
looks so cool in this way. >> Historical tradition. >> I
don't even know what he's saying. >> Struggle of communism.
The riddle of history solved. You put down the laboo. You put
down the matcha for one [__] >> Okay. Okay.
Uh straight is going to kill this guy. >> Um uh rude. Rude.
He's just immediate. That's a random clip I clicked on and he
just called you out instantly. That's amazing.
Shade thought she had this guy. Okay. Two holes. Haha. Two hole
has. And he immediately called out the Laboo. >> Why the
plastic cover? To keep it
>> Classic classic clip coming up here. >> I don't
give a I am a Mongaloid.
In my heart, I'm a Mongaloid. That is what I am. We are a ward.
That is what we are. Yes, we are that. We are 100% that. >> That's
not something to be proud of. >> It is something to be
proud of cuz the Mongols are the ones who created civilization.
And you created nothing but barbarism. You're the [__]
barbarians. You destroyed the treasures of mankind. The Mongols
only united it. What the [__] do you know about civilization?
What the [__] do you know about pride? What the do
you have to be proud of? Except looting, genociding, and destroying
the cultures and peoples and wealth of this world. What the do
you know? Can's
>> Well, you're the one here chimping out. >> I am
chipping out cuz I'm aing human being and you're a little soy
boy little [__] You don't know who the I am. I Dave
Smith atick
moms who spit on his own people. J ST LK. Get your ugly. Put
him off the screen. I can't look.
>> Sorry. Thank you, Rabbi Leitz. Thank you very much for
the >> You're right. It is what I am. >> I had to
interrupt the clip. But >> well, it's an anthropological
term. It doesn't actually
point. You ugly disgusting
ugly disgusting
barbarian smell. Did didn't the Mongols literally loot and genocide?
I don't get it. Famously so, actually. Famously so.
Literally the rapiest people of all time. Like basically provably
mathematically the rapiest people ever. >> Do you think
Hos is smart? >> Uh, okay. Kind of. Kind of. So, I don't
know if you've ever talked to anybody about Hos's writing, but
apparently H has like a
H writing about like communism, like uh Marxist Leninism in this.
Apparently, >> it's intense. It's intense >> theorywise.
He actually is like a very smart person. I've had >> Yeah,
he knows. He knows the theory. He >> Yeah. I think like
Sunday said this, but then there's another guy in DG who's like
a big lefty who's like a really smart guy. He's like infamously
like one of the smarter political guys in in the Destiny Discord.
Not even DG chat, but the Destiny Discord. And he was telling
me one time that he's like, "Dude, I thought this guy's a" And
then I read his and I'm like I I just couldn't believe I didn't
he didn't believe that Hos wrote it. Like he he couldn't Yeah.
He just believes stupid things.
>> And he doesn't know. That's literally It's like the
one subject area expertise that he has. Everything else like
lost. It's like Ben Carson being a amazing neurosurgeon, but
he's a [__] literally in every other capacity.
>> Yeah. Yeah. No, not Anti Cherry. I'm talking about Irk.
Irk.
IK.
That guy.
I used to talk to that guy a lot. I haven't talked to him in
a long time. Probably because I'm banned from the DG uh what
do you call it? Chord.
>> Bam. Bam. Yeah. Murk. Not Merc, but Irk. IK. Dinosaur
bones dude. Yes. He's the guy who predicted the dinosaur po bones
talking point. Uh told Destiny to ask uh what was that guy's
name? Uh the guy who's
Oh, I can think of it if I just think. It's not Logic. It's uh
Oh, who's the guy that got asked about dinosaurs?
Logo Datalus. Lo Logos Datalus. Yes. Logos Datalus. Yes, that
guy. All right. Good times. Old times.
I I kind of that Hos clip to be honest with you guys.
Fentes also doesn't believe in the bones, right? I feel like
Fentes would be somebody who would joke about not believing in
the bones and >> No, he doesn't believe in them. That's
why I don't understand why anybody starts off any debate with
him other than making him say that evolution is fake and that
bones were just placed there by Satan to deceive humanity,
>> which is what he believes. So >> he'll just >> or
ask him about transubstantiation
>> and he's going to sound >> like most Catholics
don't even believe in transubstantiation even though it's like
a core tenant of it. >> Yeah, I'm sure. >> And they'll
be like what? Oh yeah, it's the same like all of these people
again. Cand dos like if you look on her Twitter or whatever,
she was one of these people that was like Lil NasX and like Nike
are promoting like satanic footwear because they're doing a collab
together and he like talks about the devil too much in his like
gay lyrics. These people are like that that's who they are at
their heart, you know? >> They're awesome at their heart.
>> Like just religious uh fanatics that are like stuck
up and would like absolutely
be horrible. Like if you if you were your parents, you would
[__] them. >> I think uh how do I put this?
I think uh I when I hear Fuentes talk about it, I see like a
smirk there when he talks about it that makes me think like it's
kind of put on, but maybe not. Maybe you think it's sincere.
I I don't think he's a very I understand that he lars as like
a Catholic. I don't think it's very
but maybe that's just a read you get. >> Everybody says
that there's no such thing as basically like a sincere Catholic
online with the exception of like that like Tren Horn dude that
everybody else is like fake >> that Trenorn >> that's
how most Catholics operate. I'm telling you
>> that that Trent Horn guy is a weirdo. >> He's
a way >> other than the fact that he's a Catholic. Why?
>> Uh was there some He said some weird Oh, dude. He's
got like weird videos and he got in a fight with Fentes and they
found some like weird [__] on him. I cannot remember
what exactly it was now. I'm trying to figure it out. It It was
some weird they found on this guy. I thought it was funny that
when he debated Jasmine Jafar and whatever, he uploaded it onto
YouTube and I think he gave a disclaimer like, "Uh, warning,
my debate opponent is wearing something very immodest. I'm sorry."
And it's like cuz she's wearing a top like mine.
>> Uh, yeah. What What can you do? Okay. Jasmine Jafar
is like the ultimate hypothetical. Do you remember the um not
Isabella Moody, who's the other person who's a right-winger?
She's like uh Hispanic name >> the the cake cake cake baking
lady who got the cake baking >> controversy over the t-shirt.
>> Jasmine's like the ultimate
>> No, no, no. >> Not Emily saves. Sarah talking
about Yeah, I knew I knew Cherry would know it for sure. Isabella
Duca. Yeah, Jasmine Jafar is like that. But like actually like
I don't think Jasmine Jafar can wear things and it not be like
provocative to most people.
That's unlucky. Okay, that sucks. >> That sucks. >> Depending
on how you look at it. >> Or or lucky. Uh she probably
never >> poor Jasmine. Poor poor Jasmine with that perfect
physique. That sucks. Yeah.
>> Okay. Uh
all right.
Okay. Are we going to go back? This person was debunking. I don't
think they finished debunking yet. All right, we're we're only
we got 7 minutes and 30 seconds of debunking that we haven't
watched yet. I'm going to >> It would be illegal for Tik
Tockers to upload anything longer than like 2 minutes. I'm serious.
>> I I mean, I would agree with you maybe if I wasn't four
and a half 4 hours and 50 minutes into a stream. Okay. I don't
think I can I don't think I can go the first stone on not being
concise. That's >> myself with a Congress person. I just
let chorus know so that they know that congress person is open
to booking and other people in chorus can do it too. Accidentally
I always forget to let chorus know. Like I don't think I've ever
told them that before. But that's not what's important. What's
important is that they're literally acknowledging here that you
can book it yourself. And the fact that the person who wrote
this article claims to have read through the entire contract
but like here it is clearly written that what you stated in your
article was categorically false. Like that is quite concerning
about >> I think like I said that's it's the all thing
funneling all when yes even in their article they acknowledge
the second part of that >> integity like contracts are
long and confusing that's why people have
>> collaborate fully with chorus regarding all such separately
arranged engagements wait collaborate fully with chorus regarding
all such separately arranged engagement contractor further blank
participate in newsroom
well hold on what does that mean collaborate fully with chorus
regarding all such separately arranged engagements hold on doesn't
that change this as well to like oh suddenly it is funneling
collaborate fully with chorus. Wait did you see this Aaron?
>> No cuz she never moved her head or at least not I didn't
know that she moved it to that point. This this probably would
have been done Pisco's interpretation. [__]
>> Collaborate fully with Chorus regarding all such separately
arranged
>> Hold on. Can I see where this is? It's like somewhere
here. >> Your journal. These contracts are long. Like I
get that these contracts are long and confusing. That's why people
have
>> contractor further something. >> Managers to help
them. But you don't >> further agrees to participate in
>> Don't write an article about it unless you understand
what's going on. This whole article is just written like you
know this group they have money so they control them and
>> no that's not that's not what's happening. If there
is someone in this cohort that you are like they are too much
of a shill doing whatever the Democratic party says. It's not
this program that's the reason for that. I don't know how to
put this nicely. It's either a personal moral failing by those
people or it's a different contract they're under that says they
can't criticize Dems. But it's not this one because I'm under
this contract. And you can catch me on the daily making fun of
Andrew Cuomo Cory Booker calling for Chuck Schumer to lose his
job. Take your pick. I have heard of contracts that exist that
restrict what people can say bad about Democrats, but this is
not one of them. This contract actually has no >> wait
contracts through this organization or another organization.
>> No bearing on a single thing that we ever post. Which
brings me to my next section. The next part, and this is a really
important part. I'm going to try to explain this as well as I
can.
>> Wait, do we know about opt- out provisions in this contract
chat? Are there opt- out provisions? >> But feel free to
comment questions. Is that the contracts reviewed by Wired prohibit
standard partnership disclosures? What she's talking about, okay,
a standard partnership disclosure is when you make a video in
partnership with an or like the ACLU and so then you put ACLU
partner as a disclosure in your caption. There is very important
context left out of this article of why the standard disclosures
aren't the kind we use at Chorus and that's because Chorus never
pays us to make a video. The author of this article actually
said that in a comment. You're correct that Chorus doesn't pay
you to post specific content. Chorus is a training program where
I learn things like what lights to buy if I want to film a YouTube
video. And what
>> Wait, so why would it be a problem if you just said
like Chorus partnered for like a bunch of your content? Why is
that explicitly disallowed?
>> Cuz she doesn't have to. So
>> yeah, but but I I believe the claim from the article
is prohibit standard partnership ship disclosures in that >> do
not put that we are involved in this >> out of this article.
We using a loophole you see
>> the standard disclosures aren't the kind we use at Chorus
and that's because Chorus never pays us to make a video. The
author of this article actually said that in a comment. You're
correct that Chorus doesn't pay you to post specific content.
Chorus is a training program where I learn things like what lights
to buy if I want to film. Dude, could you imagine all of them
coming out and basically making this statement and having the
Sinclair thing like sync it up? I'm not paid to say anything.
Chorus is simply a training program. I ask things like, "What
light should I use?
>> Is the Chinese knockoff ring light as good as the brandame
ring light from Amazon? Which Amazon ring light should I purchase?"
This is the toughest question when deciding how to make thousands
of dollars on social media. Okay. Which ring light should I buy?
I don't know. >> Invaluable guidance that Chorus provided
to me as an upand cominging content creator that aspired to make
an democratic lean content. Like you could totally hear it. >> Which
lighting best suits your >> video and what policy experts
are saying about jerrymandering in Texas and National Guard in
DC. So since chorus is about like personal development and they're
never paying you to make a video, of course you're not putting
like chorus partnership in your caption.
Uh, of course you're never Wait, why why wouldn't you? What if
you felt like you're getting paid to make your content, like
you're getting paid to be a content creator with a certain opinion,
and so you feel like you should disclose that? Why is that disallowed
would be my question? >> You know, maybe that guy saying
it's kind of seems kind of predatory. Was it
>> Anyone who read the sentence, >> you ever you
ever hear the uh what what is the expression?
Um Oh, there's an expression that used to apply to Facebook and
stuff. Oh, right, right, right. Like if uh if it doesn't even
work, right? Where where it's like if you're not paying anything
for something, you're the product. It's like if you're getting
paid that they're getting something from you. Nobody is paying
you money. >> If something is free, then you're the >> Yes.
Yes. But that I don't even know if that applies to. They're literally
paying you. That means they're getting something in return. Do
you know Do you understand what they're getting in >> No,
they're just doing it so they can personally develop her. They
really care about her. >> When they tell you it's just
that you have to understand what they're getting in return, right?
And if you don't understand that, if you're if you do just think,
if you do actually believe what you're saying here, then you're
a mark, right? >> They want her to just be the best >> her
that she can be and they're happy to support her.
>> what's the what's the predatory aspect here? cuz I feel
like I I haven't read something that you guys have cuz it feels
like they're just trying to find like small creators that agree
with them politically like tick some kind of boxes and then they
try and like boost them up so they're like astroturfed or you
know they can kind of like improve their content, become better
content creators, put out those talking points that they already
like, right?
>> What is the equivalent? Why are they getting paid $8,000
a month for like information that is free if you have
>> to learn? >> Because they want to like try and
support content creators that like agree with a political kind
of a certain political kind of like brand them. You might say
no I'm kidding. But >> I think that's what I'm getting
at like that it could be predatory that way. >> I could
explain to you why I think it could be a problem and it's not
guaranteed to be this but why it could be a problem. Okay. What's
like the equivalent to this organization, the rightwing? What
do you think is the best
>> Uh, Tenant Media. >> TPUSA to me is the best equivalent,
right? That's what people will say, and I know TPUSA built itself
up as, hey, we just we're just challenging. We're just going
to like, you know, facts over feelings. We're going to have debates
and stuff. And what they turned into was, hey, you can be over
here except unless you're going to criticize Israel,
>> It was a joke at first, though. >> What's the
joke? cuz they pretended to be like an organization for college
Republicans and like for young people, but it was like exclusively
fun. It was like Koch brothers funded or whatever and it was
a bunch of old people that liked it and they had a really big
Facebook presence, but when you actually look at the rallies
that they have on college campuses, when you look at the ambassadors
that they get, they get like no views. They get like no traction
>> Yeah.
College chapters.
>> I think the thing to me is as you build this up, it
might be nothing now and they might be investing in something,
right? Like I I am familiar enough with tech billionaires at
this point to know that every tech billionaire understands land
and expand. Hey, if we can get a whole bunch of people on our
side, if we get a bunch of people doing this, we can build up
a couple creators. We can like build up this brand, get it trusted,
get access to these politicians, right? We can start actually
making plays. We can start actually doing stuff,
right? with agree with that and especially in terms of like they
weren't paying their biggest creators, >> just real quick,
with Tenant Media, they weren paying their biggest creators to
actually make content in any way for them. They were just basically
paying them to make the content they were already making, right?
They just wanted the legitimacy of having those creators around
them. But that legitimacy there was underlying that legitimacy
was a was a long was a longerterm plan from the Russians to I
guess just skirt you know >> it was to infiltrate American
conservative media because they had RT funnel money through this
fake billionaire that didn't exist named Edward Gregorian and
then they created a shell company in the United States based
in Nashville that Lauren Chen and her husband ran and then Lauren
Chen was the one that got all these people on board and they
did disclose to them that the billionaire who was involved with
tenant media was was Russian. But >> yeah, but I'm I'm
saying I don't think that was to I think they had already infiltrated
conservative media. They just wanted their same position back.
They were SRT paying conservatives to make pieces, right? To
write pieces for them. They were already doing that. They just
wanted their piece. They wanted that position back where they
could pay these people again because they weren't going to be
able to because of the sanctions, because of the war in Ukraine,
right? So RT got kicked out of the US. I think they just wanted
that same arrangement back where they could pay these people
and actually
like have some sort somebody who's willing to put out somewhat,
you know, favorable talking points to them. I don't think it
was like a great, it was a strategy that was done like very reactionarily
to the sanctions coming in from the Ukraine war in my opinion.
You guys might disagree, >> but I Okay, so in terms of
in terms of like the access to politicians, I can get that. in
terms of trying to build it up now. Maybe if they're being involved
through through the entire process, then sure, like they can
capture that politician as well, that becomes part of the funnel,
other people can speak to them. Great. They're building this
whole like network of communications. Maybe they become like
the default guys that um that like Democratic party go to when
they want to get a politician on like some social media feed.
But in terms of this whole pay structure and it being predatory
to existing clients,
that just kind of seems like it doesn't really work cuz it feels
like you've basically got the prettiest flowers in the bunch
being picked out and they're being like nurtured or whatever.
But it seems like they're just getting like a good deal, but
they're just trying to like proliferate those creators >> to
try and like
certain political >> Yeah. Yeah. I don't know if I agree
with Predatory. I don't know if I agree with that. I'm saying
that like I think these people are
>> using their
I guess like integrity
>> to back this program and to build something that I don't
know that they necessarily agree with cuz they don't know what
the broader vision
since you got blamed for my actions in spite chat. I figure I
may as well donate to >> Hold on. Spencer,
I am so so so glad that these have almost no place in the Australian
Labor Party. >> Okay. Uh, Spencer, thank you for the five.
I don't think I got blamed. I think Quimma got blamed, but >> thank
you for the five. I appreciate it. >> Potentially predatory.
>> Oh, potentially. Oh, right. It's like I think they just
don't see they're
>> they're they're joining something. They're getting paid
to echo certain points, right? To I I think I think it's really
about those rapid response days having like more inline messaging.
I think that's a big thing. And while they're not going to be
forced to do that, I think that is, you know, if they've got
a creator who's informed, >> I just wonder like if they
don't if they don't adopt that and uh like incorporate it into
their content, is that a mark against them? Is that is there
like a report card or rubric that they're graded on that if they
don't adhere to it over a long enough period that they're not
really, you know, learning the skills? And by learning the skills,
that means you would of course of your own valition start to
naturally incorporate these sorts of things into your content,
right? Is that what they mean? Well, that's I assume that's the
way it would work, right? Like that
>> but there's no party line to tow, by the
>> The more you go in a direction that fits with the the
goals of the organization, the more you will get interviews,
the more you will get exposure, the more you will get collaborations.
And if you're not doing that, well, we're just slowly going to
like weed you out over time. I there's nothing that prevents
that. There's no oversight into that. And if that's what they're
going for, then there will be a passive system that doesn't explicitly
say you have to follow what we say, but it will reward the people
who do f who do follow, right? Who do reamplify the points they
want amplified and they can create that entirely through positive
incentives and zero negative incentives. Zero like, hey, you
have to say this or else you're getting kicked out. And that's
why I'm talking about land and expand is like, yes, it will take
money. It will cost a lot to get that to happen over time, but
that is absolutely could be a thing here. And that to me
is a lot of why like the secrecy could come in with this. At
least for the smaller creators
is they they don't want it to appear like that that everybody's
going to use the same talking points. They don't want to get
accused of like I said the Sinclair the Sinclair media effect.
This is cynicism. Why is it cynicism? Why is that difficult to
Isn't this how exactly how everything else works? What is what
what do you mean isn't this exactly how everything else works?
any sort of funding. Uh
probably
usually you can see the intention of the person doing the funding
and the intention the the thing that's weird is that them saying,
"Oh, we just want to develop these people." >> the intention
isn't just usually clearly seen, right? It's spelled out. >> Sure,
it could be spelled out. But I'm saying that
basically if somebody's going to say, "Well, isn't that how everything
works?" It's like, "Okay, then why am I being why when I say
that that's what I think is happening, am I being called like
a like a [__] liar by Hutch or something?" Right?
If I if I say that I think you're setting up a bunch of positive
incentives to to tow the Democratic party line and somebody goes
somebody responds to me and says, "Hey, isn't that just the way
all funding works?" I could go, "Yeah, >> That just politics,
man. Isn't this what the right does? What's wrong with it? >> Yeah.
I >> like I thought the whole point is that the left is
supposed to have like again some higher standards than the Republicans.
They're not just going to like seek to raify and replicate. >> I
don't even I don't even believe that. I don't even believe that.
I think you could just say I'm going to sync to that to that
standard. But the issue for me is a bunch of people just yelling
at me that like I'm uh crazy for for seeing this and thinking
that it is just trying to recreate Republican what Republicans
are doing with intent.
>> Having like a fueled meltdown on Twitter over the last
few days over this stuff like he's 100% just worried about his
>> He doesn't have a like
Hutch. Yeah. >> I don't know if I should
I assumed he was just from how much he was glazing it. Oh, >> I
don't I mean I don't know if Hutch is part of it or not. Hutch
Hutch is just like Listen, I hate I hate anybody left of me,
okay? And I'll take I'll I'll join any side to go after these
people. That's Hutch's that's Hutch's position, okay? You left
to me, I'll kill you. >> They'll understand why when they
grow grow up, you know, get older. >> It would be crazy
to be in Progressive Victory and then flip directly to this.
By the way, I think some people were responsible with the Progressive
Victory stuff. I think some people disclosed like pretty quickly.
I think some people were responsible with that. I don't have
any problem with like the progressive victory thing from like
a
like systemic perspective.
You just got to just got to disclose, man. Criticism is that
they should be more transparent. Sure, the framing was sensentized.
IMO from Taylor Loren. I think uh the things that were the biggest,
you know, accusations in there were the non-disclosure and that
it's like dark money to begin with. And I think both of those
things are true. You could say the framing of like, oh, it's
a shadowy thing, but it is kind of shadowy. And there were apparently,
it seems like I've not seen anybody post a contract to say this
didn't happen, right? It's and there's no retraction from from
Wired yet. It seems like there probably was something in there
that prevented people from disclosing this.
Everything I've seen from people saying like including this person,
right, this person even says, "Oh, there's no standard partnership
agreement or so there's no you you can't use like a there's no
standard partnership disclosure." Sorry. Even she's coming in
and saying, "Well, that's kind of expected because they're not
paying you for content, so like why would you do a disclosure?"
It's like, but it sounds like they're disallowed. Well, the PvP
people do seem to feel attacked, Matt Slice. That is that is
very clear to me. A lot of the PV people reflexively started
defending this. I would assume some of them not even necessarily
knowing what was going on here, that they kind of just felt like
this was like PV and then they immediately started defending
it. And by the way, when PV started getting pointed out, I want
to I want to point out to everybody here, when they started pointing
the PV out, they immediately
wiped their like existing structure, as far as I know, they went
from, oh, we're paying people out of a corporation that's that's
totally opaque to, oh, we're actually paying you out of the the
actual pack now, and it's going to be all reported correctly,
and your your money's coming out of this. Like, that [__]
switched up if I'm not if I'm not mistaken, right? They went
from not reporting, not reporting, not reporting to suddenly
all of the influencers were getting paid through the pack and
being tracked by the FC.
>> That was an accident. >> People complained. >> That
was an accident. >> Oh well. Oops. >> It was literally
just like an error. >> Oopsie. I don't recall a single
PV person. Well, to be fair, Queen Bee, I believe there's mostly
uh I believe it was mostly, right, who were in PV before it was
like exposed in a way.
I'm trying to think of like the creators that were in it. I don't
think Loterbox was in it yet if I'm not mistaken. I'm not sure.
I don't think Reley was in it either. Trying to think of the
other people that were in it. It was like Connor and Wick >> on
the Hole. >> Oh, and the lefties who were also stupid.
Xanderhal.
Yeah, the lefties who were also really dumb. IRI. Oh, boy. I
think Cherry was almost in it, too, if I'm not mistaken. And
when I say I think, I I'm pretty sure she was just about involved.
And then she Yeah, I think she was in some of those early conversations.
Josiah did not disclose he was paid. Was Josiah making a I don't
think Josiah was making a lot of money from them. He might not
have been disclosing, but I have less of a problem with like
Pac-Man and people like Josiah not being um as you know forthcoming
cuz when it's like 2% of your income, it seems like much less
of a conflict. Maybe that's wrong, but when it's like 2% of your
income, I don't really think I care,
right? Josiah was
way more than he was getting from PV.
Josiah is 100% the coolest, most mature person about the whole
thing. Okay, Dan's getting in on the action. No way. We've got
a Dan can't stream tweet. Dan tweet. Dan tweet. Legal action
should be taken against Taylor Loren and Kai Nast for letting
this go out with no factchecking. I think, bro, hold on. This
should destroy her reputation forever. Hold on. The real truther
says this should destroy her reputation forever. Let's let's
take a look at what >> independent journalist bunch of
cloud chasing influencers on here have gotten >> I know
I did not just hear Taylor Loren less than a year ago in December
2024 was apparently honored to be called a creator when she left
her job as a traditional journalist to what focus on her own
career as a solo creator went on the Piers Morgan show which
many would claim is one of the most desperate things one can
do call other people cloud chasing influencers
>> going on Piers Morgan desperate. So Taylor is the person
who wrote this article. By the way, I have >> a low brow.
I don't know if it's
>> I feel like it's pretty good exposure for a lot of people,
but maybe not. >> Have no involvement in any of this, who
if you remember from the beginning of last month in July, I had
an issue with, especially when she resorted to WS, which is what
this stands for tactics. When she tried to discredit me by >> Wait,
she's doing white supremacy tactics. Hold on. with especially
when she resorted to WS, which is what this stands
for tactics when she tried to discredit me by >> her. This
is white supremacy. Appreciate the effort you went through, but
I think this video shows why we need journalists and tech reporters
to cover the news. Apple does not collect identifying data that
could be subpoenaed. I appreciate your efforts to look at to
look into this issue, but you should speak to tech and data privacy
experts instead of posting misleading speculation. The media
is writing about this app because it went viral and hit the top
of the app store. There's nothing suspicious about that.
This is white supremacy right here. This should destroy her reputation
forever. This guy calls this post on
White supremacy.
Cool, bro. Are there even humans on social media anymore? I swear
to God, as a total aside, I as a total aside, I just have to
go and show some replies I got to like the previous tweet. Hold
up. This one right here where I'm like I'm joking about Nicholas
not realizing that Desty lies about people. Okay. And I'm looking
at like the replies to this. I don't know why anyone gives ab
not that one. Lies about the context of a video where Destiny
is arguing against someone exploiting a 19-year-old. Then cries
about people lying. Lol. This didn't happen. There's there's
just a couple of these that I don't understand at all in terms
of the replies, like what the English is. Destiny doesn't mention
Nick in this clip. So, unless there's some context directly before
this this that clarifies he's speaking directly about Nick, the
instant denial comes across as a confession. I'll not be watching
Nick's stream to find out though, as he is insufferable. Well,
that's just funny. This one, we don't trust y'all. the liars.
He Nick definitely did. We all know it. Sorry. These were the
ones. Okay. Is Dan Dan's almost certainly following this guy.
Hold on. Prince Mir 27. Oh, he's not. He's not. This guy's a
big DJer or whatever. I've seen this guy a lot around. That's
a That's certainly a squad you're assembling.
Lauren made Pixie sue him. I don't really like JTock that much,
but this is such a point. I'm surprised you're an actual human
being and not just a Twitter rage bot uh rage bait bot account.
I'm JTO
making the tweet. A bunch of people address me as like Nicholas
Yoro, too. Why do you sound like that?
Sorry. Just there's so many people who are ESL responding to
this tweet. I'm very confused. I'm not on Twitch right now, Dickers.
>> Thank Oh, good. Sure thing. >> What? I'm literally
not on Twitch right
>> No, I know. I just I just realized Yeah. Sorry. All
right, you could read the chat as well. >> Mainly Asians.
I forgot you guys called them Asian. >> Well, yeah. Everyone
was in the No, everyone was in the chat thinking like, "Oh my
god, this guy's like thinking about like Indians." If think about
No, the whole continent. >> Nobody will ever believe a
commentary YouTube. It's the cesspit of YouTube. You're all rats
that turn on a moment's notice to be the first to make a story.
Durio
told Willie to make the video. Oh, wait. I'm not following Dan,
so I actually won't see if Dan's like one of these guys. or if
Dan's following one of these guys. Oh, it won't even pop up for
me anymore.
Dan might have been following some of the Hold on. Let me go
back to Dan's thing. Nah, it actually don't care. Never mind.
Where's the lie? I just Dude, I don't know. I got so many responses
to this that just seemed odd. I listened to that stream. You
talked to him before he called the cops. A once sane man makes
a regarded decision after Pumba says his peace. You've blocked
me, of course. large really funny atjstock plus community will
still hate Willie M show when there's no arrest.
Sorry I
and aside it's not really >> by telling me that I'm not
a real journalist. Well, that's hilarious because here you are
now claiming that >> influencers in my story are so desperate
and they cannot stop making up just boldface lies >> because
you a real journalist clearly didn't do your own research before
you wrote this article and instead of just taking it down like
you told me to. Is this guy gonna say what the inaccuracy is?
Cuz there's there's like two inaccuracies and they're in the
first like paragraph. So, it should be pretty >> You decided
to make six videos where you keep justifying yourself about how
wrong you are. >> So desperate. >> You see, this
organization called the Omodar Network has this program called
the Reporters and Residence Program where for 6 months these
journalists receive a monthly stipend. And look who is on that
list. Taylor Loren. And in
>> so like
transparent >> repeating this lie. Just repeating this
>> Transparently funded. This guy's just making the Oh,
that's rough, >> dude. Not only did the 1630 group, which
is the same dark money group that Taylor talks about in her article,
donated to >> He's karate chopping. Shut up. It's not a
karate chop. He's just pointing. Okay. He is actually kind of
karate chopping.
>> I'm sorry. He is actually I'm sorry. This is him. That's
literally He is literally He is literally I'm sorry. He
as is actually happening. Okay.
>> Relaxing on it.
>> He can't help it. Okay. Stop.
Stop. Wait. Who are you asking this to? Dickers. I see you posting.
Did they respond right away? Was it Hutch? >> Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. I uh I asked him if he
did it in any way. >> He took his time. He took his time,
>> dude. Did he? No, he responded like instantly to you.
We should invite him on the stream. Would Hutch come on the stream?
That's the question. Let's look at my dicker tweets here. Replies.
Replies don't load because of the VPN. >> I linked it to
you from his side.
>> Oh, perfect. >> Or from his open. Okay, so
the guy who made Chorus's frequently asked question section on
their public website must have really [__] up, I
guess. Participants receive a monthly stipend. What is this pointing
at? No, there is no do not tell you're giving money. What? This
is fine. Joining Chorus, the incubator program. Yes. Were/ Are
you affiliated with Chorus? I kind of assumed you were due to
how you were tweeting about it. I just got told you never said
whether you were a part of it or not. Brother, game this out.
Taylor says she has a list of everyone in that cohort. She engaged
with one of my posts earlier today. If I was talking all this
while secretly being paid by this group, in what universe would
she not expose me immediately? Yeah, dickers. Have you ever thought
about not being a >> Listen, okay, even that maybe. Okay.
I' I've engaged with way too much Destiny content. Even that
Even that dude, I was thinking like, well, h that's not a H.
He didn't say no there. That's a Oh, interesting. I didn't ask
about being paid either, but yeah, I'm just going to assume he
means no. H is a simple guy. >> that's an innocent guy.
He wouldn't lie. >> That's the kind of non
you look. >> That's so brutal. Just say just say he's an
idiot.
It's actually worse to be like he's he's a simple folk.
I just I don't think he's like macavelian like uh like Steven,
right?
>> Uh I don't think >> my brain has been in that
mode like passing sentences like Aristotilian logic style like
well what is exactly contained here literally
>> listen I I was going to make a joke about being on my
computer but you know what I don't I don't even have it in me
right now. Okay god I don't have anything like that on my computer.
H I can't get past the phrasing of that. It just makes me like
laugh when I think about it. I've never had any material like
that
on my computer.
>> I just imagine a face change looking into a camera.
>> Well, you know, I never cheated on you with all like
that that pregnant in
>> it's it's a lie. >> That's the question to ask
any GG. your girlfriend comes up to you and says, "I've never
I've never cheated on you with Tyrone." You would break up with
her instantly, wouldn't you? You absolutely would.
Uh, if she was telling the truth, they would if she was That
was a clever lie to to put them in torment. I think they would
stick that out. Okay. I'm just saying, we all know it.
All right. Hutch is still tweeting about Hutch is still going
hard about this. Uhoh. I dude I is I want to see maybe he's responded
to anybody pointing out that like the
uh the Omdar [__] is a
Has he responded to anybody pointing that out that that's a lie?
>> Well, they're not a journalist so they don't have the
same responsibilities to not propagate lies on the internet.
Aaron, tell Hutch to come play. I mean, I have an open line of
communication, but he's not going to do that just cuz I message
him. >> You're friends with him on Discord?
>> Yeah, I am. >> Hutch. Wait, he's not even live.
Why is he sitting in like the live channel of his Discord server
right now?
>> Because he forgets to leave it
>> I do that all the time. Actually, I sometimes just leave
my mic live and I go do other [__] in my house. And
>> like one time there was a PV thing and >> in in
like the PV server thing or whatever. I noticed he was still
in there and I like came in and I was like, "Hutch, did you need
something else?" And he was like, "H" he like screamed and he
forgot that he was in it. >> He's taking care of business.
You interrupted just >> he was he was like he was like
I was literally just gaming and I didn't remember that I had
like stayed in this
>> taking care of business. >> Yeah. What do you
What do you mean what does that mean? What does that mean? >> All
All I'm saying is like I've given those excuses, you know, >> gripping.
Jesus Christ. You get your [__] mind out of the gutter.
>> Yeah, that's disgusting. That's disgusting. Brazilian
lad. Why would you suggest something like that? >> It's
not It's unrealistic. It's I'm not offended at the fact that
it's disgusting. It's like why would he know? I just don't think
that Hutch is that incompetent. I'll be honest that like not
only does he not realize he's in a Discord thing that he was
like and no >> Dude, what the is Hutch doing on Twitter,
man?
He's replying to me
654's
19 followers, zero following.
>> Is this just like >> he's in the trenches? >> I'm
sure it's just a coincidence that not a single one of is viciferously
pro Palestine. Dude, unfortunately, he's just going to go cherry
pick like the total, right? Like people who will just say without
really looking into anything. He's a spaz. He's a bit of a spaz,
but he should come on the stream still.
Oh, a shady or has a nice public-f faced website. Never seen
that before. Featuring creators you guys were alleging are alleging
were sworn to secrecy. He's like making the worst arguments to,
>> right? Like
I
How do you get around the fact that like >> why I assumed
like he was being paid for
>> I thought I thought he's paying defended his paycheck.
Dude, >> it's like okay,
I don't know how to explain this to >> I thought this guy
was tweeting as if it was like, you know, him tweeting is the
only thing that's going to like get his mortgage paid at the
end of the month. like he has to go on this crusade on X.com
otherwise otherwise his kids are going hungry.
>> Dude, the crazy thing here is like this is like actually
what I feel like Hassan and like uh lefties used to do was they
would just keep saying something until they could like set that
as the narrative and say like basically make their lie reality.
Like I feel like this used to happen before. I feel like I used
to recognize this happening from Twitch pull. And that's what's
happening now with the Taylor Loren thing. So many people are
trying to tweet out that like it's a totally debunked article
that's like defamatory. It's slander. She should be sued. And
it's like it's like I do any of these people understand?
Do any of these people under Oh, maybe he's watching. What the
I'm going to take that as a no. Just wondering, mate, that's
a hard no. You just responded to you again. But yeah, it's like
they're just trying to cement this and it's like, dude, this
isn't true. The article isn't debunked. I man. Okay. But also,
can I really say it's not debunked when I haven't even watched
Ally finish debunking yet >> and was like, "That is so
evil." Because a lot of people who consume content don't necessarily
know the way that the logistics of like, you know, your partnership
labels work. But I am for >> this Tik Tok feels like an
hour and a half to still. >> This is the world's longest
Tik Tok. It's like 2 hours.
>> I know. We're almost halfway.
>> We're almost halfway. We're almost halfway. for the
relevant conte
misleading. And then I also highlighted the section, I accidentally
talked about it already earlier in the video, the you know, creators
will not publicize their relationship with Chorus or tell others
they're a member of the program without Chorus's prior express
consent. This is the protecting small creators part, but also
lots of things in contracts are written very strict in case of
legal emergency. I've told plenty of people casually that I'm
in Chorus, and Chorus does not care. But they've expressly
>> dude. Okay, but you have to understand >> but
you told them but you told them first lady.
>> But also also just really quickly, why
didn't Chorus go and say like, "Hey, here's some corrections
we'd like to here's our statement. Here's like a statement how
we dislike this. Okay, here's a statement how you're getting
something wrong." Why did Chorus not comment
on this article? Well, they did right in the correction or sorry,
that >> No, that's the lawyer. >> The lawyer guy
commented. >> I don't believe he's actually representing
Chorus in this case.
>> Actually, it doesn't clear to me. I assumed. Yeah. Who
would he Who else would he be representing? Himself. >> Well,
I think he's talking about Oh, I think he was in one of he was
leading one of these things, >> right? I think he was leading
one of the >> Something like that. Yeah, >> but I
think he's correcting his part, but I don't think he's broadly
speaking for chorus as in this is our statement on it. I think
he's saying for the part of the article I'm referenced in, here's
some corrections for my part, right? I think so. Anyway, >> told
us that that's fine. This is just for if someone does something
like diabolically evil and then chorus has to sue them and they
can just be like, "Girl, the contract like it makes it easier
in court." They don't really care about it otherwise. It's not
top secret. If you want more examples of people who've publicly
talked about chorus for a while, I'm happy to provide them. Feel
free to comment. Um, I just used Heidi's example cuz I think
it's it's just very obvious. Okay, I have two more things to
address in this video and then feel free to comment if you have
more things you want me to explain. But the first is we've talked
a lot about what course is not because that article led people
to believe that it was this, you know, plot by the DNC to be
able to just pay people off to blindly obey them. Now that that's
been >> I so I get how the by line of the article might
lean in that direction, but I don't think that's the tangible
like actual material if material
alg or I don't think that's a part of the material allegations
in the article. I just don't think so. >> Debunked. Let's
talk about what course actually is. I have my Google calendar
for the week here to explain. Every morning we start off with
a news update meeting. Okay, we meet for 15 minutes. I wake up
and I'm immediately just told what the news of the day is. Um,
and we all get a chance to >> daily message updates,
guys. I just want to This is like some big scary thing where
you get the impression that like the DNC is using this to push
like a a a narrative for us. Okay. But when I wake up in the
morning, the first thing I hear is Brian Tyler Cohen's voice
in my ear telling me what the messages of the day should be.
That's so much different. Brian Tyler Cohen is like pot. The
DNC is like Chuck Schumer, Nancy Pelosi. They're old. They're
ugly. Brian Tyler Cohen's awesome. and he just tells me, "Okay,
that's not quite what it is." But
do we not see how this is like a little bit a little bit like
that? Like that it's not the most insane
assertion in the world when you have a daily meeting that you
go to. >> Today, the IDF liberated the souls of 19 Palestinian
children. >> 19 people free from a life of terrorism and
destitution. Okay.
>> ask like questions if we want to know how a specific
lawsuit is developing or what is Trump expected to do next with
the National Guard, right? We're just making sure we're all the
most informed. These are very brief. Sometimes they're 5 minutes.
Then three times a week in the afternoon, we have a more like
specific training. On Mondays, we have technical trainings. That's
where we learn about a specific platform. So like someone will
come and explain how you start a Substack or how you start YouTube
long form. On Wednesdays, we have advocacy training, which is
where we hear from an expert in a specific policy field. So recently
it's been a lot of people who work in like immigration explaining
ICE or explaining the logistics of the National Guard, that kind
of thing. And then Fridays are a little bit more flexible. Um,
and they're optional. I haven't gone to them, so I like won't
speak on it. And that is the weekly schedule. And the whole point
of it is that you're like developing your channel over the course
of 6 months so that hopefully by the end of it, you can be your
own self-sufficient full-time content creator because people
who work in politics on social media often have a hard time getting
funding.
>> Like it's hard to make it your job. But the right does
a really good job of making it people's jobs. such that the political
right actually pushes out 500 times as much content as the political
left. That's an actual statistic. Every single day they are outperform
and I learned that at my advocacy training. Okay. 500 times more.
I don't know what that means by the way. I that could be true
maybe. I don't see how that is true but it's maybe >> without
paper that that stat is like totally worthless. Like actually
>> I don't know what that means. ing us in >> Like
is it is it like somebody doing straight up like conspiracy theories
about like lizard people on YouTube is also the political right
maybe
>> absolutely will be. >> I'm not totally >> incredibly
because they just make sure that people can do it as a job. That's
what this program is trying to accomplish to counter like the
manosphere. Last thing I want to talk about is my belief that
the election funding system in this country is like fundamentally
broken. I want to talk a little bit about the logistics of dark
money because it's not really explained in this article. Dark
money is when someone does fundraising for the purpose of influencing
elections, right? Like giving it to a campaign through nonprofit
organizations so that they don't have to disclose the identity
of the original donor. So, for example, right, we all know that
Donald Trump is helping the Quomo campaign in New York.
>> wait, do we all know that? Is that true? >> No,
we don't all know that. Here's what we know. Andrew Cuomo. There
was a leaked audio obtained by Politico where Andrew Cuomo said
to donors that he expects that there will be some sort of boost
or bump from Trump because he will effectively signal that maybe
Cuomo would be a better alternative to Zoran who is currently
like leading in the polls. Although I saw a poll from Newsweek
that said maybe not. Um but Curtis Leewa the Republican candidate
was saying no because of it doesn't like Cuomo's argument is
that he knows that he can work with me. like we've done that
before like in you know when I was uh governor and he was president
during the pandemic or whatever which is kind of rewriting history
but
Curtis I think is correct that Trump won't do that because of
his bail reform measure that like let criminals back out into
the streets of New York City. So I I don't see I like even though
he doesn't like Zoran I don't see him kind of like hinting like
maybe you guys ought to vote for Cuomo or whatever but he also
can't endorse the Republican because that Republican is like
an anti-Trump >> Okay. Okay. Well, I I'm going to go with
her. She's the one that's got the definition up for dark money.
And you know,
I think we she said we all know, so I feel like I should know.
Am I not dumb if I don't know that Andrew Cuomo is expecting
a huge boost from Trump? Dark money. >> Now, that's embarrassing
for Andrew fundraising for the purpose of influencing elections,
right? Like campaign through nonprofit organizations so that
they don't have to disclose the identity of the original donor.
So >> fund is raised for the purpose of influence elections
by nonprofit organizations that are not required to disclose
the identities of their donors.
>> for example, right, we all know that Donald Trump Cuomo
campaign in New York. Now that's embarrassing for Andrew Cuomo
is the problem. So if Trump wants to give money to the Cuomo
campaign but doesn't want anyone to know it was him, he can give
it to a dark money organization that again gives it to Cuomo
and nobody can trace it back to
>> No, I think that's actually not necessarily true. I
thought the whole point of dark money and super PACs was they
can't explicitly um coordinate with a candidate. Giving the money
directly to Cuomo would be coordinating with the candidate. This
doesn't work in any avenue of dark money that I've heard of that
you could just take dark unlimited dark money and fund it. Give
it directly to a candidate.
Is this person saying maybe chorus needs to have a training session?
Okay, an hourlong training session on how dark money works. >> Donald
Trump, I don't like that system. And to be clear, most Americans
don't like except for the billionaires. We're pretty much all
Republican and Democrat, like on the same page that that system
is really bad. So, I was excited to join this incubator program
at Chorus for a while. It was the first of its kind on the left.
I felt like it was really important for me as a leftist to be
there. I mean, this way I can encourage people to be more critical
of Israel, encouraging them to push their representatives a little
bit harder. To me personally, I find it important to be in rooms
with people who are less critical of the system than I am because
I have the hope of like nudging these people into more strong
advocacy. And that's not always going to work, but sometimes
it does. And so when the leaders of course came to us and they
were like we're finally launching the program we finally found
someone to fund this. It's the 1630 fund I was like ah right
okay not the biggest fan of their other work. Let me think on
this. And obviously I ended up joining but it was not without
serious deliberation with my friends and my family and my management
and the the people who run chorus. And ultimately like I want
to sort of lay out for you who may be curious what my thought
process looked like. I decided that my distaste for the fact
that the 1630 fund funds some, you know, congressional Democrat
campaigns with methods that I don't like was outweighed by the
potential benefit of separate program where they have no control
over what be a leftist voice in a first of its kind incubator
program for 90 people to combat the manosphere. I was like, you
know what this >> is that what they're
Ryan Tyler Cohen is doing. He's combating the manosphere. >> That's
nonpartisan, baby.
She said that earlier, right? She said that about like Red Pill
podcast like the manosphere. >> I She did say that earlier.
>> I'll be real. I feel like they've had entire brainstorming
sessions on how they can come up with things that they can be
against and be united about that are not political topics that
they can like organize under that are not political topics that
they can use as like a reason for existing so they can say that
we're a non-political nonpartisan organization.
That's what this sounds like to me. Perhaps being anti-Trump
was a little too on the nose. But >> pro democracy. >> Pro-democracy.
We're pro-democracy, >> I'm not anti Trump. I'm just >> One
to talk over. You could join the voice chat if you want. You
want to come in and give a different voice to this? >> Give
a normal a normal take. Invite this normal lad into this voice.
>> By the way, I'd totally invite Hutch on to speak about
this. You could go listen. If you know Hutch, you have any connections
to Hutch, I'm totally willing to speak to Hutch on this. Where's
Hutch at? Also guys, 37 minutes left on the stream. You know
what to do, okay? You know what to do. You want the stream to
go for a long time. Keep donating. Keep throwing money in. Okay?
Put some money in the bucket. All right? Put some money in the
bucket. Thank you very much. I'm not even going to do a full
show. Okay? Hutch is a [__] He would never debate
you. That's pretty rough, dude. I don't know if I'd say that.
You got $40 from Nick Fentes. I might have gotten $40 from Nick
Fentes. I got 14.88 plus 25. What is that? That is almost 40.
You know what? That is another hour. That's true. You're you're
going to be debanked for that probably.
>> Uh I don't know about that. >> And you'll have
nowhere to put your money except like in a piggy bank or under
your mattress. >> Listening is a myth. I've heard debunking
is a myth. Doesn't happen. It's interesting that Aaron is here
right now.
>> One took over. Do you you keep
Please don't just insist that other people while not being able
to defend your own opinions. Please hop in the cord.
somebody who's freaking the out from chat but won't actually
come into a voice and like talk to them about it. No way. No.
And then that never happens.
>> You keep highlighting >> I have like a Discord
or ban policy and I've been streaming for a few months and I've
had out of all of the dozens of people that I've been like you
can come debate me right now on this if you think that you're
going to BTFO me in front of all these people watching me. Come
on, come embarrass me. They never come. Even though 2 seconds
earlier they're saying I'm a [__] [__]
and I don't know what I'm talking about from chat. And all of
a sudden it's, "Oh, I'm at work. I can't talk to you. I'm I didn't
want to do that. I'll just take the ban." >> It happens.
What's up, moral? How's it going? Are you here for your apology?
>> Yeah. Uh,
I'm sorry for that tweet. Straight away. That was It was not
called for. You're not a you're not you're you're not a stupid
[__] I'm sorry. >> Well Well, we don't know
that. Morau, I uh speaking on behalf of the audience, what was
this tweet over? >> It was literally nothing. Just went
off for some reason. Yeah,
>> it's literally It's literally not connected to anything.
It's literally just Oh, wait. Why did I like that? Hold on. Let
me tweet. >> It's actually not to anything.
It's not reply to anything. You just throw it up out of nowhere.
Is at straight raid, stupid [__] Oh, >> I mean,
I can delete it. Take it down. >> I noticed that you're
uh you're getting botted by the same people. Okay, you're getting
botted. Did you notice this? You're a 10 IQ and Desi is done
with Pixie. You and your gay lovers are next though. Queenie,
you are nobody. Irrelevant sped coward.
>> I'm not above raping pixie. Those bot tweets are true.
Yes. >> I'm not above a lot of things.
>> so I didn't see that tweet. >> I didn't see that
tweet. >> He's so humble. >> What tweet? Which one?
>> I so down to earth. >> Not above that. That was
weird. That was a weird one.
>> Oh, I didn't No, I'm I'm saying that. I didn't tweet
that. The bot comments are
Apparently, I'm getting rid of Dastinger. I don't know what they're
saying. It I they're they're on something. Listen, I got to go
straight. I'm sorry. I'll delete the tweet. I didn't mean to
call you a dumb. I hope you're okay. Sorry. Bye. >> What
a guy. >> What a guy. What a guy. Just a crazy
>> This guy's crazy, man. >> Out here in a dog's
world. >> Tweeting crazy things.
>> Listen, don't use Morau's ironic humor against him,
okay? Don't Don't lean into
>> Don't lean into it like that. >> He's just a little
He'll be okay.
>> That's true.
All right, we have >> He's scared of the the top dog, the
[__] that I am. >> We have a minute and a half
left, okay, of the 2hour Tik Tok. >> If I had 10 minutes
left to live, I will put this Tik Tok on. It's the longest thing
I've ever watched. It would feel like hours. She's explaining
to us how dark money works without any understanding of like
the concept of dark money or I guess of how like super >> sweaty.
She's pulling up the dictionary definition. But you feel stupid
>> from it. And I think that the threat of fascism is so
big right now that they're >> That's another one. I forgot
about this one. I think you guys just want Republicans to win.
I think you guys just want Republicans to win. Actually, I think
that's why you're doing this. Do you want Do you understand that
Republicans do this and you guys just like kind of want Republicans
to win? is really up what you guys are engaging in right now.
Like fascism is on the rise. We have to let certain things go
when fascism is on the rise, guys. Okay?
Uh
totally unttracked money in politics. These things just have
to be put by the wayside until Trump's taken out. Okay. It's
not important. What's your dog's
>> Zelton. Good. >> Wait. Zelton Goodan. >> Elton.
Elton.
>> And I said he did a good yawn. Please don't. Good yawn.
Okay. I I was like, is that Yiddish or
weird weird >> also? That was a good yawn.
>> Yeah, I I didn't hear the Yeah, I didn't hear the the
e. It was like >> I didn't annunciate enough. It was like,
wait, it was >> too close together.
>> I think I It's fine. >> Might need to be an order
of operations, right? We need to get rid of the fascist threat
of Donald Trump trying to take everything over. And then once
me and and us buddies are in power, then we get rid of the dark
money mechanism so that nobody in the >> It's She's got
counterpoints morality.
Guys, we just have to get rid of Trump and then I can actually
stand up for my principles. First, we got to deal with >> then
my principles. Okay? >> Then I can stop receiving $8,000
when we win. When we win. It's unironic for the exact same situation.
>> Yes, it's the same thing over again. >> In the
future has to do this through a dark money funer who's the only
one willing to fund something in the future. I'm more than happy
to have dialogue with people about, you know, the pros and cons
and weighing like joining a program and whatnot. Um, but I do
want to like really emphasize um everything I have posted has
not changed at all since I joined this program. I think that's
very evident. If you know my page well, if you see the things
I talk about, uh if you see the way that I don't hold myself
back from criticizing anybody who is worthy of criticism, I think
that there is genuinely a very important conversation to be had
about the way that we do funding for all things political in
this country. And part of the reason this article frustrates
me is because instead of having a very legitimate conversation
about that, it was just like a bunch of misinformation and now
we're all just debating the fact that it's like taking everyone's
attention away from what's like really important and what the
real things we should be talking about are um and just making
a whole like. Anyways, feel free to comment any questions that
you have. I'll be responding. >> No way, dude. Taking the
attention for the I'll be in election year, guys. Donald Trump's
in office, guys. That is like I keep hearing this. Wait a lot
from Dems. >> This is the >> It's a distraction.
Everything that Trump's doing is a distraction from what? I'm
not sure. Take this [__] >> But I think Yeah,
she's saying like I don't know why they phrase it this way, but
like just say you don't want to unilaterally disarm, right? >> Why
did she bring up a definition of dark money and didn't say how
chorus isn't dark money? To bring up that Andrew Cuomo is is
collaborating with Republicans and it's a distraction. >> Hold
on. Hold on. She brought up the definition of dark money and
then was like, "Oh, the 1630 fund," which is like clearly she
acknowledges is dark money and she's like, "But Trump is president."
So, she brought it up to be like, she said this was about dark
money. Let me remind you what the definition is. And the 1630
fund, well, yeah, that's probably dark money. And we can talk
about how dark money is bad after Trump's out of office.
>> she brings it up to explain it, doesn't admit to it,
but tacitly does cuz says we can fix it later. >> No, she
she basically directly admits that the 1630 Foundation. She's
like, I'm not the biggest fan of the 1630
>> She says because of the techniques they use to get Democrats
elected. She never brings up any of the dock money. >> I
think >> it's like, well, I just like his like fashion.
It's like, well, you know, he dis disavows the anti-semitism.
I'm pretty sure the 1630 fund is infamous for being a dark money
fund.
>> Like if you
fund it, >> it's it's not but it's like that's that's not
what that's what is that's like yeah that's like saying listen
guys here's the definition of anti-semitism. Okay, here's the
definition and I'm just saying that like got some problems but
he built some roads too. Okay. Like I understand I I I really
dislike the way he gets the roads built. All right. And yeah,
there's no admission that anti-Semitic or you're anti-Semitic,
but like you're literally talking around the most infamous thing
about them. I don't know. It's something along those lines. Okay.
Not an anti-semit. I injected it myself. Okay. Terrible, terrible
stuff. I honestly have no problem with the funding mechanism
for either Republicans or Dems if the rules of the game. But
the way she phrased it was so dumb. Yeah. Well, I'm the same
I'm the same way. I'll accept dark money if that's if you tell
me that's the rules. Okay. Evil Johnny Bravo made a point earlier
that like maybe the rules are that you can't admit dark money.
You can't say it's dark money or you can't admit that it's bad,
but you also have to use it. And it's like fine, but then don't
aggressively attack me or call me a liar when I point out that
you're not actually making sense.
Okay? Just slink off into your hole and keep your plausible deniability,
but slink off into your hole. is just no just silk is funded
by um a random billionaire that's also affiliated with the 1630
fund. >> I wish Mr. Omidar
GBT
>> Mr. GBT chat GBT >> trust me we could I'll even
throw in some free shilling for Iran into the package Mr. Omidar.
Okay. Either against the regime or for the regime.
Just go ahead. You know, about 100 gifted subs would do it for
the month. Okay. About 100. eBay sponsorship. True. All right.
Let me see if we got anybody in the waiting room here. And then
>> women who jump on the stream have to cover up. Maybe.
Maybe. >> Did I get off then? If that's going to be the
rule. >> Don't worry. Don't worry. Um I Okay.
So, what do you think the biggest um the biggest like criticisms
are this then? Because I would definitely say like moving in
a direction of um like trying to monopolize access to like politicians
probably like the worst thing. Introducing
kind of like astroturfing to content creation kind of poisoning
the online political space. That would be the second.
Um
I can't think cuz I feel like everything else is just going to
target what? like speculation or like a speculative
kind of potential for something to happen, >> Yeah. I mean,
even the monopolization is is speculation, right? It's not actually
happening. There's like indications, but it's it's still even
speculation there, >> I guess. So, yeah. >> Did Taylor
No, Taylor Lens did not get funds from the Malcat Tales. That
is
Uh, let me show you. Do I still have what's her name up here?
I don't. [__] I don't have that up anymore. But what
happened is there's a billionaire who has contributed to the
1630 fund and who runs his own foundation. Through his own foundation,
Taylor Loren is a part of his foundation. He's got a journalist
incubator thing. Okay. He has through his foundation, that journalist
incubator thing that runs on its own. Okay. It's a sep It's even
slightly separated from his foundation. Transparently, money
from him will flow to Taylor Loren for $8,000 a month for some
stipen she gets. Okay, that's it's disclosed publicly on their
website that she's a recipient including the amount and the source
is known for the 1630 fund. The sources of money are not known
and it appears that there are uh parts of the contract for uh
for Chorus for the incubator program that prevent them from doing
standard partnership disclosures. They were updated with something
to say this is how you can talk about working with Chorus,
but they were they were prevented from actually disclosing, you
know, in a standard partnership way, in a standard like # Cororus
sponsored, you know, on their on their TikToks or something,
right? They're they're apparently prevented from disclosing that
way. I don't know exactly what's in the contract either, but
I've not seen anybody actually dispute that. I've only seen people
kind of talk around it instead of actually disputing it with
the contract language, which makes me feel like they're probably
incorrect. Sorry, I missed I missed Cherry totally owning Dickers
here. Dickers has this thing where he says nothing, but because
he says it in a British accent, people think they should listen.
>> He's actually swallowing a northern British accent.
I don't know if you knew this. It's not actually his like legit
regional accent.
>> Oh, yeah. I have no idea. >> Yeah, we covered
all of this, Ally. We covered all of this. Um, Brian is very
careful in how he uses it. Okay. He says the thing exactly, but
he implies some hypocrisy there. There is no hypocrisy. There's
no equal or equivalent hypocrisy in any way. So I think I think
Brian's scummy for that to be honest that Brian will take the
thing that everybody else is saying and he'll appear to amplify
it but he'll actually be very specific and say well one of the
funders of 1630 and
is you know the same person. So the money comes from the same
source. Okay well you outed Pierro Midiar as one of your sources
for funding for the 1630 fund. That is not tracked publicly anywhere.
Okay. Nobody else can go look that information up. Also, I believe
Brian just broke the rules of the group, right? I thought one
of the rules of this contract was
do not discuss funders of the 1630 fund. Was that not it? I thought
that was actually explicitly a rule via the article. Am I crazy?
Wonder.
Uh, the contracts reviewed by Wire prohibit standard partnership
disclosures, declaring that creators will not publicize the relationship
with with Chorus or tell others that they're members of the program
without Coror's prior expressed consent. They also forbid creators
from disclosing the identity of any funder and give chorus the
ability so of any funder. What the what the Mr. BTC? What are
you doing? Did Aaron lose this argument with Pisco? Uh I think
Aaron couldn't see the whole contract. I think I think there's
some >> I feel like that third clause actually would have
put a lot of our like speculation to rest. It's it's like the
most just like lawyer of like arguing over like semantics and
grammar and like what could be intimated. It's like all hinging
on like just certain like article of a like a word. Like it's
it's just you'd have to see it for yourself. It's just pointless.
>> What does funneling mean? Straight away. Does it not
does it mean this? Yes or no? Yes or no? >> No. No. No.
No. No. >> Aaron won the moment that Pisco got flustered
because he might have to create like a new invite link or something
and he just reformatted his stream to look. >> Oh, true.
Wait, what was that, by the way? What? >> I made one joke
as a follow Riverside. I made one joke as a follow-up and he
was like, "I'm about to leave the call. I'm about to leave the
call." He's like, "Dead serious." >> I thought he was joking.
I thought he was joking, but it didn't actually seem like he
was joking. He's like, "I'm about to leave right now." >> He
was very frustrated. >> Also, you probably can't comment.
So, actually, just pretend Aaron's not here. Here, I'll move
her off screen for a second. I'm going to move your camera off
screen cuz I'm going to say something that you don't want to
be a part of. Okay. How high does Pisco get before streaming?
This guy's eyes are so red when he shows up to stream. Is this
guy smoking like a full ounce of weed before he hops on the on
the cord to do the stream or what is going on? Sorry. Now Aaron
didn't hear any of that. I'm going to bring her back. Okay. It's
crazy. I feel like when he gets ready to do her take. This is
maybe this is the only way he can stomach listening to Lindy
Lee for any extended period of time. Seems possible. I'm not
saying he does it all the time. I'm just saying.
>> I'm just saying he's been crying all day. All right.
He was crying. The Riverside thing got taken down.
Uh, Riverside, >> you didn't know how to generate a new
link. I didn't realize that. But like also, there's probably
a feature on that. I didn't realize that we just had a general
security issue because it shouldn't be the type of link that
anybody can join it if they see it. We should probably have it
like password protected. I didn't realize that. >> Yeah.
Yeah. >> I didn't even know what that was when he when
he showed it, like what precisely it was at all. >> No,
he was like, "And now everybody's seen it." I was thinking like,
I bet people didn't realize that if they actually if they go
to that link, they could join this. They probably didn't know
that until you said that, so didn't think it needed to be. Um,
it was a big
>> He did. He did totally like leak it though. That's funny.
I like looked at it like, "Wait, what is that thing that he's
leaking there?" What is that link that he just gave? Is that
just like Is that so you could show cameras? Is it kind of like
Streamyard or something? >> No, because he only he uses
that overlay. I I don't use it. Stop. Stop chewing that. Jesus.
>> All right. Uh, Dickers, say something witty real quick.
I'll be right back. Give me uh 30 seconds. No, 45 seconds. I'll
be right back. >> Why are you tasking Dickers with that?
Did something change after your convo to make Pisco seem more
justified? No, actually like if we had if we had continued watching
that Tik Tok, we would have actually been able to see the third
clause and I think that would have cleared up a lot of things.
But
tick 10 minutes 10-minute Tik Tok, man. Can you blame us for
not being able to get past it? Dog kind of ugly. It's tough crowd.
Tough crowd. >> Uh sorry. I um I'm considering um I don't
know. I'm considering, you know, going to maybe doing some uh
doing a panel over this. Might be fun. Um >> get stuck
on TikTok. The dog is cute. Thank you. >> Yeah. I'm not
texting my
It's [__]
You don't understand how [__] late it is here. Jesus
Christ.
Um I I I just feel like this is like so many lessons kind of
like not learned from P surely, right? >> I wonder. I mean,
I don't think that they were looking to PV at all. Neither mistakes
nor the few successes when they were coming up with Chorus. I'll
be >> There's no way. >> So, we know that, but I
don't think >> Tyler Brian Cohen
like David Pacman never heard of Cohen. That's the one.
>> Oh, I am also thinking about like I have a couple messages
out already of I'm just trying to see if I could get a panel
together on this together on this as well. So, I feel like I
know some people who would argue like I know Lunarbox would do
a panel on this. I'm almost positive. I know that uh we need
>> Well, get Wick, my friend. My friend >> uh maybe
I know I think about doing
>> Well, I but I don't want to wait until I think he said
next week. I don't think he works weekends. >> Maybe Hutch
will come. >> I I would love if Hutch would. Okay.
I don't think Wick works weekends. though. I was thinking like
this weekend it'd be cool to talk about this before it goes away.
>> I don't think >> I know I could get
Okay. All right. That's really That's [__] up. Okay.
What? How did he earn that money from PV if he doesn't work?
Sorry. I don't have your camera up. I'm sure your response is
quite funny. Uh let me see here. I didn't have it up for me.
>> You need the dial up to like sound to play right now.
Do you have it on your
>> All right. All right. Interesting. Interesting. Porter
Beller just keeps spamming this egg and then a hammer and I'm
not sure what this means. What is this? Porter Beller, don't
clarify. Okay, don't clarify what that means. Don't Please don't
clarify.
All right, Wick will not associate with this crowd. Wick will
absolutely associate with this crowd, but uh I'm just saying
I I know a bunch of people who could argue this from the other
side. I just want to see if we'll get um I just feel like a lot
of people won't hop on. Maybe progressive brat will join. Oh,
that's a good that's a good one. Yeah, you can >> Is that
the same girl that he introduced to a pearl because he knew her
in like real life? It's that girl.
>> Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. >> Has she gotten any better?
>> Real life. No. >> Oh, apparently doesn't know
her in real >> Just knew her from Tik Tok. >> Oh
[__] Never mind. >> Only knew her from Tik
Tok. >> Maybe Hassan will join. You should get Hassan on
the panel. >> Well, I'd have to get Queen to join if I
wanted that. Okay.
>> Wait. I don't know. I don't know if I >> really
reviews his videos as we know.
>> He does.
>> Best friends. Yeah, best friends. We should
I don't know cuz Yeah, I would just like to get like a couple
people on to discuss it. I think I think Hutch would be the biggest
get though. That's the thing is you need Hutch. You need Hutch's
unhinged insane
wild man energy. Okay. That he's just going to bite like every
bullet on this. And
I don't exactly know why. It be nice to get one of these like
kind of Luke Beasley Pondering or like LIB type of creators that
do the factory mill and see how they feel about it because they
all have like an a either they have an friendship or affiliation
with Brian Tyler Cohen or they want to. So I want to see if the
chilling effect is so intense that they won't even criticize
anything related to this because they don't want to be seen as
publicly on one of the major like independent progressive political
voices. They probably would never participate because of that.
>> They might not. Well, I don't know. I That's the thing
about Hutches. I I think Hutch is just going to defend no matter
what, right? I think Hutch is all over that.
>> It would be interesting to ask him to like steal, man.
Like, why do you think people have an issue with this? Like,
can you see any possible valid reason why? And if he will really
say like, I cannot fathom a single reason why anybody would have
an issue with this. This is just a nothing burger. >> Is
a loyal soldier. He really is.
Justice for E Boy. Okay.
You ever going to talk to Connor ever again?
Uh, I don't know if Connor is ever going to talk to me again.
I said some I laughed at some donos that implied that he would
hold down a child for for one of his friends. And uh I I don't
think Connor is a big fan of that. Okay. I don't think Connor
was a big fan of that donation. He just recently left the Discord,
okay, like a day ago. I think he did not like that.
I think he was not a I think he was not a fan. That was a great
don.
Okay. Where's the lie? Listen,
it's tough one. Okay,
I'm trying to think of what else I wanted to watch on this. We
We've gotten through all of this. I've not seen
>> Majority had a reaction to it, but I'm going to dip
out. I'm starving. Yeah. >> Yeah, that's fair. Well, thanks
for coming on tonight. I'm uh Yeah, I'm about ready to get back
to reacting to stuff. So, thanks for coming on. I'll >> message
you about possibly debating this who I can get. We'll see because
I I have the same impulse as you dickers that I I would like
to see some actual conversation, some cross talk on this. We'll
see. Maybe it'll have to be through platform. Uh >> you'd
like to live stream a lobotomy. Got it.
>> Maybe that's not against terms of service on kick. >> Uh
it's definitely not. But what do you mean? We're doing a lobotomy
on Hutch. >> Uh being participating is effectively like
equivalent to lobotomizing oneself and then subjecting the viewers
to seeing that. You know, I guess that's not against >> toos.
All right. Well, I mean, someone just recently was like poisoned
on this app, right? >> Are you talking about the French
guy? >> Like to Yeah, the French guy. >> I don't
know if he was poisoned. I think he died from like internal hemorrhaging.
I think that's >> No, the toxicology report said that it
was because of something that he
>> Oh, really? Oh, >> yeah. It wasn't cuz he was
beat up. >> That's up. >> Cuz Kyle Kolinsky was like,
"They killed the man live on a stream." And then I went and looked
it up and like there had just been a report published saying
that that wasn't like it wasn't like physical injuries. It was
something that he had
>> All right. Have fun enjoying the world's longest Tik
Tok. >> Uh, it's over. It's actually over. We're all done
with that. >> Are you sure it's over? It might be. >> I
didn't even realize it was done. >> 10 seconds left. That's
spans se like, you know, several hours. Actually, >> it's
over. It's being used as a predicate by John Favro of uh
>> of Iron Man. >> Pod Save America. No. Of Pod Save
America fame. Okay. Thank you. >> Okay. Ick I feel like
I don't know if you want to do this. All right, but I'd be like
super cuz I feel like you know this better than I do. You understand
this better than I do. You've read more than I have. >> Could
you steal man what the defenses would be? >> Cuz I feel
like I barely scratched the surface here. >> What? What?
>> Unless you're directly getting paid
>> Do you want me to argue?
>> Okay. Um so >> devil's advocate.
>> I The best I can do is Republicans are doing this anyway.
If we're transparent about how manipulative it is, like basically
as a as a base premise, if you are transparent about how manipulative
you have to be to win in this political environment, you cannot
win in this political environment. And so >> shut down,
it's explicitly not not transparent, right? And it's made intentionally
opaque by the contract.
>> You basically have to agree, right? you basically have
to um not agree. You basically have to you'd have to buy into
like yeah Republicans are so bad and so dangerous that we have
to do this which I could even buy into but that's not not even
what people present as like a part of the argument which is just
[__]
I don't know. I think that's basically like the the best argument
I can do. What people actually do is they say um well can you
tell me how this is different from just accepting money to like
start my business? It's like okay who do you accept money to
start your business from? the government. There's two options.
It's like usually the government who will do that because it's
a part of like I don't know enriching the society. The government
has an actual interest in enriching the society broadly and not
themselves or it's from like an investor who's going to get something
back. So you tell me why this company is just I guess interested
in you enriching yourself or what they're getting back. I don't
know. It's different. You walk down both of these. But that argument
at JOC, you wouldn't be able to present that argument because
it would undermine the point. Yeah. Yeah, it's like a private
argument. Yeah, I'm saying that's the strongest argument you
got in my opinion. And that like you don't you don't broadly
do that like talking as an official of the group. You say that
as somebody who's not a part of the group cuz I'm trying to think
the other arguments I get is well show me where my content changes
or show me like why you think this is affecting me. It's basically
like getting money from this group can't affect me
which I think is just an insane argument to make. >> Well,
it's just a argument that misses like the meat of the critique,
right? Like I don't give a [__] about a particular
person getting like $8,000 or whatever. I don't think anyone
does, right? It's all gonna be about how it's gonna like change
the ecosystem.
sure. Like on mass on mass. Um, well, I mean, it's it's you're
creating like a an incentive for a bunch of people to agree with
you, right? And that has a shift in the ecosystem. It's still
you still care about the individuals and how they react, but
it doesn't matter whether or not one person is above it or below,
like not above it. on mass you have to assume that it will have
an effect. So yeah, sure. You were saying the same thing. >> Well,
like I said about like picking picking flowers earlier, like
the way that I just kind of like picture this is you've got like
like a hundred teeny tiny like content creators. You pick five
of them that you're going to intentionally like fund, make sure
that they can live and they don't bow out, which is why most
small content creators like stop, right? they're not get get
enough money or they don't feel like supported or like anything
like that. And so you take five of those who you politically
agree with, boss them up, they're way more likely to become big
people, right? But you've got this like you're manipulating the
environment and the natural churn of the environment to make
it so that your political like persuasion like wins out under
the guise of it just being like general
Um, yeah.
The ar I guess the argument is that Republicans are already doing
this and there's just going to be a natural Republican slant
to the environment unless you fight back in the same way. >> Maybe
I just need to look more into like what the Republicans are doing
then
USA. I think TPUSA is the big like counter-argument. And then
to me, I just immediately get like kind of annoyed cuz I think
TPUSA actually does tangibly shift like the overall like overd
window in a way that is not just that is like very direct to
like the it's like a small group of people who control that organization
and direct it. And it's it it's like about control in a way that
this group is trying to say they're not doing.
So you could say TPSAs are comparable, but TPUSA is like kind
of nefarious in my opinion.